Hallo und herzlich willkommen und guten Abend zum Chaos Radio im Fritz Blue Moon am 28.9.2017, wo wir heute, weil es ja gerade an der Zeit ist, mal über die Wahl sprechen wollen. Fragt euch vielleicht, die war doch letzten Sonntag, warum denn dieses Mal immer noch? Aus einem schlicht und einfachen Grund, weil die Wahl war für euch, glaube ich, vorbei, als ihr gewählt habt und dann vielleicht noch ein paar Talkshows geguckt habt und dann noch ein paar Artikel gelesen habt, ob jetzt Jamaica oder nicht. Aber bei der Wahl passieren noch ein paar andere Sachen. Zum Beispiel muss sehr ausgewertet werden. Und da ist tatsächlich auch Technik im Einsatz. Und genau darüber wollen wir heute hier sprechen, was da benutzt wird, was daran kaputt sein könnte, worüber man ja gerne spricht, wenn man im Chaosradio ist. Und dazu heiße ich herzlich willkommen den Danimo. Hallo und guten Abend. Schönen guten Abend. Die Katasha. Hallo und guten Abend. Hallo. Und die Elisa. Hallo und guten Abend. Und am Telefon den Martin. Ja, hallo, guten Abend. Sehr gut. Jetzt muss ich dir vorstellen, wer das genau ist. Danimo kommt vom Chaos Computer Club und war schon mal Wahlhelfer. Genau. Elisa kommt vom Prototype Fund.
Das ist richtig.
Das erklären wir noch genau, was das ist. Und Katasha heute von der FSFE, der Free Software Foundation Europe.
Genau.
Auch das erklären wir noch. Und Martin ist Informatiker.
Informatiker. Und habe mir das Programm PC Wahl angeschaut vor der Wahl.
Ah, vor der Wahl. Gut, darum kommen wir heute auch zu sprechen. So, also es geht tatsächlich darum, dass wir heute einmal durchdeklinieren, wie das ist mit der Wahl und was da sozusagen an Systemen passiert. Und das machen wir in, sagen wir drei Schritten ungefähr. Erstens wollen wir euch nochmal ganz kurz schildern, was passiert eigentlich, nachdem ihr eure Stimmen abgegeben habt. Also wie wird aus dem Kreuz, das ihr persönlich gemacht habt, dann ein Wahlergebnis? So, zweitens, wir haben es gerade schon gehört, der wird nicht überall dieselbe und auch nicht überall tatsächlich Software, aber der wird manchmal Software benutzt. Manchmal heißt die PC Wahl und die war vor der Wahl kaputt. Da reden wir mit Martin drüber, was er da so gefunden hat. Und nachdem wir dann festgestellt haben, dass es möglicherweise ein Problem gibt, haben wir dann am Ende der Sendung noch einen Lösungsvorschlag. Und das Code-Wort dafür ist, ihr müsst mir gleich sagen, ob ich es richtig gemacht habe, Public Funded Public Code?
Public Money Public Code.
Genau. Es geht also um öffentlich finanzierten Programmiercode, der dann auch öffentlich einsehbar ist.
Genau.
Aber das erst am Ende der Sendung. Jetzt fangen wir sozusagen ganz vorne an. Und an der Stelle heute schon auch, wir würden gerne Anrufer einladen, anzurufen, wenn sie folgende Kriterien erfüllen. Und zwar haben wir schon gehört, es gibt Menschen, die bei der Wahl mithelfen und die dabei auch mit Software in Berührung kommen. Was ja nicht immer funktioniert. Wenn ihr einer dieser Menschen seid, die bei der Wahl mitgeholfen haben und dabei Software benutzen, ruft doch gerne an, 0331 70 97 110 und erzählt von euren Erfahrungen. Das würde uns wirklich sehr interessieren. So, wir machen jetzt einen kurzen Durchritt, weil den langen gibt es schon. Wir haben schon mal ein Chaos Radio gemacht zu Wahlcomputern damals. Das war, glaube ich, die Nummer, ich weiß es nicht genau, ist schon ein bisschen her. Steht in den Show Notes zur Sendung, gibt es auf chaosradio ccc.de. Da wurde schon mal ganz ausführlich geklärt. Wir wollen es jetzt noch mal kurz machen. Was passiert eigentlich nach der Wahl? Chaos Radio 117. Um Gottes Willen, das war ja vor der großen sozialistischen Oktoberrevolution. Aber an dem System hat sich ja eigentlich nichts geändert, oder? Nicht wirklich. Wir haben ein höchstrechteiliches Urteil, dass das keine gute Idee ist, wenn unsere Stimmen irgendwo in obskuren Rechnern verschwinden. Der Reihe nach. Was passiert nach 18 Uhr? Was passiert nach 18 Uhr? Im Wahllokal. Da müsste ich dich jetzt mal fragen. Machst du Briefwahl oder bist du im Wahllokal? Nein, wir reden jetzt sozusagen von dem Standardfall der Wahl, nämlich ich gehe in ein Wahllokal, mache einen Kreuz auf meinen Zettel. Wer für den denn diese Urne, was ja eigentlich keine Urne ist, sondern eher so eine Art viereckige Mülltonne. Und dann gehe ich nach Hause und dann macht irgendwas Wahllokal zu. Genau. Und wenn der letzte rausgekehrt wurde, dann beginnt der Wahlvorstand mit den Beisitzern mit der Auszählung. Und wie gesagt, ich kenne es jetzt nur aus dem Briefwahl-Lokal, aber das läuft ab 18 Uhr eigentlich analog, genau gleich. Man holt die Stimmen raus, sortiert die nach einem bestimmten Verfahren. Man hat ja die Erststimmen, man hat die Zweitstimmen. Die müssen ja alle ausgewertet werden. Dann gibt es noch den Sonderfall, wo die Leute bei Erststimmen und Zweitstimmen die gleiche Partei wählen. Das ist dann etwas einfacher, weil man die einfach gleich auszählen kann. Das kommt dann auf einen eigenen Stapel. Also es ist eine ganze Menge Zählerei. Man bildet da Stapel. Also es gibt auch tatsächlich Anleitungen, wie man das zu machen hat, damit nicht jeder anfängt sein eigenes System zu erfinden. Das hält die Leute trotzdem nicht davon ab, das zu probieren. Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn man Menschen kennt, dann ist das ja so, jeder der kommt und sagt, ich habe einen viel besseren Planer, den ihr seit 40 Jahren benutzt. Das mag alles sein, aber das möchte man nicht unbedingt am Wahlabend probieren. Also da gibt es sicherlich genug andere Hürden. Ihr macht also Zettel? Genau. Und dann werden die Stimmen gezählt, wie werden die gezählt? Macht ihr einen Strichlisten auf einem eigenen kleinen Schrieb? Der wird dann irgendwo abgegeben oder wie läuft das? Es gibt eine sogenannte Wahlniederschrift. Das ist also ein offizielles Protokoll. Und da ist schon quasi vorgegeben, dass man die Zahlen passend eintragen kann. Also man stapelt sich dann irgendwie pro Partei in Zehner-Badges, also in Zehner-Einteilungen die Stimmen. Und dann kann man sagen, okay, Partei 1 hat so und so viel Stimmen. Für die Erststimme, so und so viel Stimmen, für die Zweitstimme und so weiter. Und dann kann man das hinterher zusammenfassen, macht einen Strich drunter, noch nicht, na das muss man machen, weil das steht nämlich auch schon in dieser Wahlniederschrift. Und dann rechnet man die Sachen mit dem Taschenrechner im Zweifelsfall zusammen. Und rechnet das dann noch mal jemand aus? Die Unterlagen gehen, also das ist natürlich so gebaut, dass wenn man die korrekt gezählt hat, davon muss man halt ausgehen, es wird nachgeprüht. Aber zählt dir nur einer oder zählt dir dann noch mal einer? Ich kenne das nur so, dass so gehandhabt wird, dass tatsächlich ein Stapel von einem gezählt wird, dann geht der weiter zum nächsten und dann wird der Stapel, den der gezählt hat, noch mal gezählt, um sicherzustellen, dass weder aus Versehen noch absichtlich da Stimmen verloren oder zu viel gegangen sind.
Also ich kenne das auch ähnlich von Parteitagen, da gibt es ja auch immer Auszählungen bei Listenwahlen und da war es so, dass man immer an Tischen saß mit so, weiß ich nicht, Gruppen von vier, fünf Leuten und dann gab es immer einen, der war verantwortlich für den Tisch und dann haben die untereinander geswitcht. Das heißt, jeder hat nochmal die Stimmen nachgezählt von dem anderen Tisch. Ich gehe mal davon aus, das war so ähnlich bei euch.
Genau, das wollte ich auch damit sagen, dass der eine nimmt sich den Stapel vom anderen jeweils vor. Okay, und dann wird das auf diesen Zettel geschrieben? Genau. Und dann? Dann gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder die Sachen stimmen fast oder sie stimmen richtig. Das kann man ja sehen, wenn man sich irgendwo vertan hat beim zusammenrechnen. Sie gehen jetzt davon aus, die stimmen richtig. Das stimmt. Dann ruft man eine Telefonnummer an und gibt diese Zahlen durch. Und die Zahlen sind dann, das ist die sogenannte Schnellmeldung und die ist dafür gut, dass halt möglichst schnell die Stimmen erfasst werden und möglichst schnell irgendeine Zahl, die muss nicht auf die letzte Stimme genau stimmen, verbucht werden kann. Das endgültige Ergebnis, was man dann raus hat, kann davon noch minimal abweichen. Aber das Spiel sozusagen für die Statistik, die an dem Wahlabend erstellt wird, das offizielle Endergebnis kommt ja erst viel, viel später, spielt das erstmal in dem Maße keine Rolle. Aber es wird auf jeden Fall sichergestellt, die Leute sind einmal angehalten, sicherzustellen, dass sie am Ende des Tages ein korrektes Ergebnis haben. Das müssen sie auch dokumentieren. Also diese ganzen Papiermonster, die man hat, sowohl die Wahlzettel als auch die ganze Dokumentation, die man anfertigt, die muss man hinterher komplett in Umschläge eingetütet, in diesen Unbehälter wieder zurückgeben an das jeweilige Wahlamt. Und dort wird es dann archiviert, falls es Zweifel gibt. Falls man immer nachzählen will. Man kann jederzeit nachzählen. Aber ihr meldet das per Telefon? Wir melden das in dem Fall hier in Berlin per Telefon. Also wir hätten es gerne. Nee, warte. Und das letzte Ergebnis wird dann wie weitergegeben? Also das endgültige Ergebnis des Wahllokals? Das Wahllokal wird niedergeschrieben. Und diese Niederschrift landet dann? Landet dann. Am selben Abend? Das wird, also meine Erfahrung endet tatsächlich da, wo ich diese Dokumente übergebe. Und die Wahl in der Schrift wird von den Sachen, die archiviert werden, abgesondert. Deswegen gehe ich davon aus, dass die Sachen, die Niederschrift nochmal jemandem zugeht, der dann die Zahlen auswertet. Das heißt aber auch, du kommst an keiner Stelle mit Softwareberührung und siehst auch niemanden, der mit Softwareberührung kommt? Präzise, das ist auf die nächste Ebene. So, und dann kommen wir jetzt nämlich zu Martin. Hallo Martin. So, wir müssen, bevor wir über den ganz konkreten Fall sprechen, nochmal genau erklären, an welcher Stelle der überhaupt ansetzt. Wenn man gerade gehört, im Wahllokal selber gibt es gar keine Software. Du hast jetzt eine Wahlsoftware gemacht. Und das ist jetzt schonmal der erste wichtige Unterschied. Es geht nicht, was manche Leute missverstehen, um Wahlcomputer. Also, dass Leute irgendwie per Computer wählen oder so. Sondern, was genau ist diese Wahlsoftware? In welcher Stelle im Wahlauszahlprozess setzt die Software, also die Softwares, die Programme, die es gibt, wo setzt die an? Was passiert da?
Also, Software wird an vielen Stellen eingesetzt zur Wahl, zur Wahlvorbereitung. Aber hier geht es dann um die Auswertung der Wahl. Also, man könnte hier auch Wahlauswertungssoftware sagen für diesen Abschnitt der Wahl. Und die kommt ab der Gemeinde, also ab dem Wahlamt der Gemeinde, wo aus den Wahllokalen dann diese eben berichteten Schnellmeldungen zusammenlaufen nach 18 Uhr, 19 Uhr, 20 Uhr. Die treffen da telefonisch ein und werden dort in einer Software erfasst. Das ist sozusagen die erste Ebene, auf der Wahlergebnisse digitalisiert werden. Und dann geht das weiter. Es gibt ja dann die Wahlkreise. Die Wahlkreisleiter haben auch eine Software laufen, teilweise ist dieselbe Software, teilweise eine andere. Die Kreise geben die Ergebnisse dann akkumuliert weiter an die Landesebene, zu den Landeswahlleitern. Das sind meist die statistischen Landesämter der einzelnen Länder. Die haben auch eine Software. Teilweise ist es immer noch dieselbe Software, die auch auf Gemeindeebene eingesetzt wird. Oftmals ist es eine Lösung, die für das gesamte Land selbst programmiert wurde. Und von den Landeswahlleitern geht es auch per Software am Wahlabend weiter dann zum Bundeswahlleiter. Ich glaube, vom Land zum Bund ist dann diese IVU-Elect-Software eingesetzt, die in den Niederlanden schon zum Einsatz kam. In Berlin ist auch dieselbe Software im Einsatz auf der Ebene der Kreiswahlleiter. Da bin ich mir jetzt aber nicht 100% sicher.
Also da kommt Software zum Einsatz. Es gibt verschiedene Programme auf jeden Fall. Und das beginnt ab der ersten, ich sag mal, Managementebene. Also die erste Ebene, die nicht mehr konkret mit Wahlzetteln beschäftigt ist, die fängt an, Software zu benutzen. Diese Schritte dazwischen wird dann sozusagen immer was, ich sag mal, ausgedruckt oder irgendwie in einer anfassbaren Kopie weitergegeben oder angerufen? Oder wird da tatsächlich auch so, man schickt eine Datei hin und her?
Also tatsächlich hängt das ein bisschen von ab. Wir reden ja momentan über die Wahlnacht. Das heißt, das sind die Schnellmeldungen, die übertragen werden und nicht die Papierwahlniederschrift. Und für diese Schnellmeldungen, die in der Wahlnacht übergeben werden, gibt es verschiedene Übermittlungs- und Übertragungswege. Meist, also von den Wahllokalen an die Gemeinde ist es das Telefon, was wir eben gehört haben. Von der Gemeinde dann an den Kreis und an das Land sind das meist digitale Übertragungswege. Da werden tatsächlich entweder Daten in einer webbasierten Erfassungsmaske, also Web-Formular eingegeben und direkt an die Server des Landes geschickt. Teilweise werden die Daten lokal auf Rechnern bei der Gemeinde erfasst und dann als Datei übertragen. Teilweise kommen da Datei-Transferprotokolle zum Einsatz. Teilweise in besonderen Ausnahmesituationen werden diese Ergebnisse per E-Mail übertragen.
Verschlüsselt oder unverschlüsselt? Oder signiert vor allen Dingen?
Bis vor dieser Wahl auch unverschlüsselt.
Oh mein Gott. Nur zum Verständnis sozusagen. E-Mail ist das so ziemlich unsicherste Kommunikationsmedium, was man sich vorstellen kann, weil es da theoretisch nicht nur möglich ist, dass sie da mitliest. Was im Fall von Wahlergebnisse nicht so schlimm wäre, sondern man kann theoretisch auch zwischendurch den Inhalt der Nachricht eigentlich ändern. Was ich fragen wollte ist noch, wenn du sagst, da werden Dateien in deinem Geschäft digital übermittelt, das kann man sich auf zwei verschiedene Art und Weise vorstellen. Das eine ist, da wird zwar eine Datei verschickt, aber die öffnet dann wieder jemand. Also ich sag mal ein Office-Dokument, ein Textdokument und trägt die Daten wieder aus. Und das andere ist, die Gegenstelle hat auch eine Wahlsoftware und öffnet die Datei und importiert sozusagen die Daten. Oder es ist den Menschen, die man sozusagen noch mal live gesehen hat. Gibt es da beides oder was ist da der Fall?
Also ich kann keine absolute Aussage treffen, da wirklich jedes Bundesland eigene Lösungen umgesetzt hat. Meist, in den meisten Fällen werden diese Daten tatsächlich automatisch in diese Software importiert, die auf der nächsthöheren Ebene läuft. Dass das selbe Softwareprogramm ist, was auf verschiedenen Ebenen läuft, ist das voll automatisch, da wird das aggregiert, automatisch von der Software. Wenn das nicht automatisch läuft, dann denke ich, gibt es meist eine Art Datei-Drag-and-Drop-Upload über Webformulare zum Beispiel.
Das gibt es auch.
Aber die Daten an sich, die werden entweder per Drag-and-Drop oder per automatischem Dateitransfer übertragen. Aber angeschaut im Detail, ob diese Übertragung geklappt hat oder dass da noch mal ein Manueller, die neu eintippen oder irgendwas stattfindet, glaube ich jetzt nicht.
Also der wichtige Punkt an dieser Stelle ist ja, die Leute im Wahllokal zählen das quasi von Hand aus und rufen dann an. Und ab dieser Stelle muss man sich darauf verlassen, dass die Software genau das tut, von dem man annimmt, dass sie es tut und zusätzlich, dass die digitalen Dateien genau das beinhalten, was sie beinhalten sollen. Okay, das wird noch wichtig. So, jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, also wir reden jetzt eigentlich nur über die Wahlnacht, also wo es um die Schmerren umgeht. Wie ist es denn mit dem offiziellen Endergebnis? Wie kommt das zustande?
Also wie schon eben gesagt, gibt es ja die Wahlliederschriften, die in den Wahllokalen angefertigt sind. Und bis zum Montagmorgen sind die eigentlich alle bei den Gemeinden eingetroffen, indem die Pakete mit den Stimmzetteln zusammen mit der Wahlliederschrift bei der Gemeinde abgeliefert wurden. Und werden dann dort noch mal kontrolliert, geprüft, ob da alles stimmt, plausibel ist. Und werden dann irgendwann auch weiter zur Kreisebene geleitet. Das findet da sozusagen in den nächsten Tagen statt. Also das findet jetzt gerade statt für die Bundestagswahl zum Beispiel. Und diese Wahlliederschriften sind dann eben nicht mehr digital, sondern werden tatsächlich halt per Boote oder Händisch hin und her geschoben, also übertragen. Da gibt es keine digitale Übertragung.
Und es gibt ja die verschiedenen Ebenen, die immer mehr Stimmen zusammenfassen. Gibt es dann nochmals eine Papierversion? Also macht die Gemeinde noch mal die Wahlliederschriften und fährt dich sozusagen eine Metawahl-Liederschrift an?
Das ist quasi in der Bundeswahlordnung niedergeschrieben. Da gibt es verschiedene Paragraphen, die Regeln, welche Anlagen beizufügen sind von der Gemeinde. Die Gemeinde summiert oder fügt quasi eine Übersicht an diese Wahlliederschrift hinzu, die die Ergebnisse aus der gesamten Gemeinde, also alle Wahllokale beinhaltet, und dann eine quasi eine Summe darunter. Das wird dann an den Kreis weitergeleitet. Und der Kreis, auf der Kreisebene wird dann irgendwann eine Wahlliederschrift zur Feststellung des amtlichen Endergebnisses anhand dieser Niederschriften gefertigt. So laut Bundeswahlordnung zumindest.
Okay, also theoretisch ist das amtliche Endergebnis, was wir irgendwann bekommen, tatsächlich dadurch zustande gekommen, dass Menschen Dinge auf Zettel schreiben.
Das wird meist angenommen. Es gibt aber auch hier wieder also quasi schon erste Auflösungserscheinungen. Beispielsweise in Hessen wird diese Kreiswahl-Liederschrift, die dann das amtliche Endergebnis für den Kreis erhält, tatsächlich automatisch erstellt. Die wird ausgedruckt aus dem Computer. Das kann ich gerade zitieren. Die Zusammenstellung wird für das endgültige Ergebnis der Wahl im Wahlkreis vom Wahlwerb Hessen nach vorliegenden sämtlichen Ergebnissen und eventueller Korrekturen automatisch erzeugt. Das steht im offiziellen Wahlerlass. Das heißt, dort gibt es gar keine, dann nimmt niemand diese einzelnen Niederschriften, der Gemeinden, addiert die zusammen und spiele Zwischensummen, sondern das wird aus dem, diesem Programm, was auf Landesebene läuft, automatisch errechnet, ausgedruckt und dann unterschrieben. Also es gibt ja auch schon erste Auflösungserscheinungen, aber traditionell soll das eigentlich anhand der Wahlniederschriften ermittelt werden.
Gut, also theoretisch ist es noch so praktisch, kann man sozusagen nicht mehr garantieren, dass es wirklich so ist. Jetzt hast du immer wieder sehr viel Wert draufgelegt, dass es von Bundesland oder Gemeindeebene immer unterschiedlich ist, was da benutzt wird. Kann man sagen, wie viel Wahlprogramme es gibt, wie viel unterschiedlich und wo die herkommen?
Ja, kann man. Ich glaube im Spiegel gab es dazu einen sehr interessanten Artikel, wo tatsächlich versucht wurde, eine vollständige Karte Deutschlands aufzulisten, welche Software wo im Einsatz ist. Ich fasse das ganz grob zusammen. Es gibt IVU Elect auf Bundesebene. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine deutsche Firma. Ich glaube, die kommen aus Berlin. Die machen eigentlich das Verkehrssoftware. Ja, gut. Die zählen halt auch Verkehrs-Fx und so weiter. Dann gibt es die Lösung PC Wahl. Die war jetzt, stand vor der Wahl recht unsicher. Und da gab es ja eine gewisse Berieterstattung dazu. PC Wahl wird eingesetzt z.B. in komplett Hessen auf Gemeindeebene und Wahlkreisleiterebene, in Brandenburg komplett, auch auf Landesebene und in anderen Ländern sporadisch. Also je nach Kommune, die unterscheiden sich da dann doch. Dann gibt es OK Wahl. Das ist auch wieder eine eigene Lösung. Und dann gibt es noch Win, V, Vis. Das ist noch eine ganz alte Lösung. Also es gibt da wirklich ein sehr fragmentiertes Bild an Software, die zum Einsatz kommt. Und auf Landesebene gibt es dann z.B. in Hessen das sogenannte Wahlweb Hessen. In Brandenburg wird PC Wahl auf Landesebene eingesetzt. Berlin wird, glaube ich, IVU Elect eingesetzt auf Landesebene und so weiter.
Also das ist sozusagen ein kunterbunter Strauß an Programmen, die, ich stelle es mal in Vermutung an, nicht unbedingt dieselbe Sprache sprechen. Also die Daten sind dazwischen nicht frei austauschbar, oder doch?
Nicht ganz. Also ich kann das am Beispiel Hessen nochmal kurz darlegen, wie das funktioniert. In Hessen werden ja bis zur Wahlkreis-Ebene die Daten mit PC Wahl erzeugt, also digitalisiert, akkumuliert und dann von den Wahlkreisleitern, nein, von den Wahlamtämtern der Gemeinden schon, von denen werden die Daten per drag und drop im Browser auf eine Internetseite hochgeladen, die das Wahlweb ist. Das Wahlweb Hessen ist diese Landeslösung des Statistischen Landesamtes. Das ist einfach eine Internetanwendung, die kann jeder öffnen. Die liegt auf daten.hsl.de. Da gibt es einen Link Wahlweb. Da muss man sich ein Passwort und Kennwort anmelden mit Kennwort und Belutzunahme. Und dann kann man per drag und drop die Wahlergebnisse hochladen. Diese Lösung nimmt Daten, also exportierte XML-Dateien aus PC-Wahl an. Da geht der Wahlleiter der Gemeinde hin, exportiert eine XML-Datei und lädt die in dieses Wahlweb hoch.
Also XML, nur ganz kurze Erklärung, ist ein Format, wie man Daten strukturieren und aufschreiben kann. Wir machen jetzt gleich die erste Pause um Chaosradio. Ich hätte nur noch eine ganz grobe Einschätzung gerne von dir. Und dann kommen wir zu deinem Spezialgebiet, nämlich PC-Wahl. Und zwar Softwareentwicklung im Jahr 2017 und vor allen Dingen auch Softwaredesign. Kann ja schon sehr viel. Und es gibt ja tatsächlich Mitarbeiter, die kann man auch tatsächlich sehr gut benutzen. Wenn du jetzt die Wahlsoftware so ganz generell einsortieren würdest zwischen oh mein Gott, lass mich in Ruhe das Ding auf dem Bildschirm macht, dass ich krank werde und wow, das ist deine Software, mit der ich wirklich jeden Tag gerne arbeiten möchte und ich vertraue dir auch, auf dieser Skala, wo ungefähr sind da die Wahlsoftwaren, denen du begegnet bist?
Die Frage ist tatsächlich nicht so leicht zu beantworten. Wie gesagt, es gibt viele Wahlsoftware. Die, die wir uns angesorgt haben, war leider auf der Skala sehr unten, wo ich gesagt hätte, vor 20 Jahren, vielleicht, ja, das erscheint mir sicher, alles, was so nachkommt, hat dann aber gezeigt, dass das sehr unsicher ist. Der würde ich also nicht vertrauen. Ja, also ich würde sagen, nein, diese Software ist nicht vertrauenswürdig. Beziehungsweise es gibt keine Möglichkeit für mich, da Vertrauen zu gewinnen, weil ich es auch gar nicht beurteilen kann. Weil diese Software auch nicht ersichtlich ist für den normalen Bürger.
Genau, wir kommen gleich sozusagen zu dem Teil, wo wir ganz genau mal darauf eingehen, wie PC-Wahl. Also nach der ersten halben Stunde haben wir gelernt, es gibt Programme, die sind dafür da, um dieses eine demokratische Grundrecht, was wir haben, nämlich die Wahl, so auszuzählen, dass dann ein sicheres Ergebnis rauskommt. Und was Martin da entdeckt hat, das entsprechen wir gleich in der nächsten halben Stunde. Jetzt gibt es erstmal ein bisschen Creative Commons Musik. Die kommt dieser Sendung komplett von Prolator, vom Album Live Playing Tricks. Und der erste Titel ist Destiny. Das war Destiny von Prolator beim Chaos Radio in Fritz, wo wir heute über Wahlen und wie sie ausgezählt werden reden. Und in der nächsten halben Stunde wird es darum gehen, wie kaputt eine Software kann, die auch sein kann, die auch damit hilft. Vorher gibt es aber die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Fritz präsentiert. So, so oder so.
Im Fall der deutschlandweiten Erpressung mit vergifteten Lebensmitteln haben sich bei der Polizei erste Zeugen gemeldet.
Die Polizei hatte vorher Bilder eines Verdächtigen aus einer Überwachungskamera veröffentlicht.
Der oder die Erpresser drohen damit, deutschlandweit Lebensmittel in Supermärkten und Drogerien zu vergiften, die Behörden raten deshalb beim Einkaufen darauf zu achten, dass Verpackungen nicht beschädigt sind.
In Estland beginnt heute Abend ein EU-Sondergipfel.
Bei einem gemeinsamen Abendessen sprechen die Staats- und Regierungschefs über ihre jeweilige Vision von einem zukünftigen Europa. Ab morgen wollen sie dann in lockerer Atmosphäre über die weitere Digitalisierung Europas beraten. Es geht unter anderem um den Ausbau des schnellen Internets, den Datenaustausch und die Cybersicherheit. Auch in Brandenburg sollen bei Autobahnenunfällen Sichtschutzwände aufgestellt werden, um Gaffer abzuhalten. Bei Unfällen machen Schaulustige immer wieder Handyvideos und Fotos.
Ein Sprecher des Infrastrukturministeriums sagte, dass dadurch die Arbeit von Polizei und Rettungskräften dramatisch behindert wird.
Andere Bundesländer setzen die mobilen Wände schon erfolgreich ein.
Hertha BSC hat sein erstes Auswärtsspiel der Fußball-Europaleague-Saison verpasst. Hertha hat beim schwedischen Östersunds-FK mit 0 zu 1 verloren und muss mit nur einem Punkt aus zwei Spielen um den Einzug in die K.O.-Runde bangen. Die aktuellen Temperaturen liegen in Berlin-Spandau bei 15, in Kreuzberg bei 16 Grad, in Eisenhüttenstadt und Grünow sind 14 und in Falkensee und Ludwigsfelde 15 Grad.
In der Nacht kann es ein bisschen regnen und die Temperaturen gehen auf 12 bis 8 Grad noch runter. Morgen wird es dann wieder schöner.
Vor allem nachmittags gibt es viel Sonne und es bleibt meistens trocken mit 19 bis 24 Grad. Vorsicht auf der A10, dem südlichen Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Spreeau.
Zwischen Genshagen und Rangsdorf liegen Reifenteile auf der Fahrbahn auf der mittleren Spur.
Vorsicht außerdem auch im Kreis Telto-Fleming auf der Lindenstraße zwischen Jütchenhof und Schias.
Gibt es Gefahr durch ein Rind auf der Fahrbahn. Vorsicht auf der B169, Älsterwerder Richtung Cottbus zwischen B96 Senftenberg und Sädlitz liegt ein totes Tier auf der Straße.
Vorsicht auf der A2 Magdeburg Richtung Berlin zwischen Thesen und Sieser.
Gibt es Behinderungen nach einem Unfall auf der rechten Spur. Vorsicht außerdem auf der B320, Bergenklau Richtung Lübben zwischen Pindow und Starkow.
Gibt es Behinderungen durch Straßenschäden. Auf der B167, Silo Neu-Hartenberg am Bahnhof Silo Gusow schließt die Schranke nicht mehr. Bitte besonders vorsichtig da am Bahnübergang, denn die Züge gefahren auf Sicht. Auf der A113, dem Zubringer Schönefeld, gibt es statt einwärts eine Sperrung zwischen Schönefeld, Nord-
und Adlershof wegen Wartungsarbeiten bis um 5 Uhr.
Und im Stadtverkehr Berlin in Tiergarten ist die Straße des 17.
Juni gesperrt. Da wird die Feier zum Tag der Deutschen Einheit aufgebaut zwischen Großem Stern und Brandenburger Tor.
Und auch die Ebertstraße ist zwischen Dorothen und Beerenstraße zu.
Ansonsten, wo es geht, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW. Und jetzt gibt es im Chaos Radio in Blumen die Chaos Computer Club Nerd News, geschrieben von Mo und präsentiert von Max Ketter. Equifax gehackt.
Einbrecher konnten der Wirtschaftsauskunft High Equifax monatelang Datensätze von über 140 Millionen US-Amerikanern entwenden. Dazu kamen die Kreditkartenkarten, Daten von über 200.000 US-Bürgern. Außerdem wurden Akten von mehr als 180.000 US-Bürgern über Korrekturanträge zu ihren Datensätzen gestohlen.
Und auch die Schadensbegrenzung war von Pannen durchzogen.
So verwies zum Beispiel der Twitter-Account des Unternehmens mehrmals, statt auf die eigens dafür geschaltete Webseite auf eine ähnlich lautende Phishing-Domain. Außerdem stehen hochrangige Mitarbeiter im Verdacht, kurz vor der Ankündigung des Schadens ihre Unternehmensanteile verkauft zu haben.
EU-Breitband-Studie.
Die EU-Kommission hat kürzlich eine Studie zur Breitbandversorgung in den Mitgliedstaaten und benachbarten Ländern veröffentlicht. Demnach können erst drei Viertel der Haushalte einen Internetanschluss mit mindestens 30 MBit pro Sekunde bekommen.
Über VDSL wird fast die Hälfte der europäischen Heime erreicht. 96 Prozent der EU-Aushalte können mit LTE-Geschwindigkeit mobil surfen.
In der digitalen Agenda der EU ist aber vorgesehen, bis spätestens September 2020 alle Haushalte mit mindestens 30 MBit pro Sekunde zu versorgen. Chelsea Manning darf nicht nach Kanada einreisen. Bei dem Versuch, die Grenze nach Kanada zu überqueren, wurde die US-Staatsbürgerin von einem kanadischen Grenzbeamten zurückgewiesen.
Als Grund gilt Mannings Vorstrafe nach den US-Spionage-Gesetz.
Zwar verkürzte der ehemalige US-Präsident Obama ihre Gefängnisstrafe, doch nach kanadischer Rechtsprechung dürfen Menschen, die in einem anderen Land vorbestraft sind, nicht einreisen, wenn die Straftat in Kanada zu einer Haftstrafe von 10 Jahren und mehr führen würde.
Die Nerd-News vorgetragen von Max Ketter, geschrieben von Mo und nachzulesen und mitzuklicken unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Vielen Dank.
Aus so vielen unterschiedlichen Richtungen, dass wir uns einen ganzen Abend Zeit nehmen, die besten und neuesten davon zu spielen. Hör doch mal. Musik. Mit Saruahomsee und Christoph Schrag. Immer montags ab 20 Uhr. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de slash Musik Streams.
Herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo wir heute über die Software reden, die dazu benutzt wird, um die Stimmen auszuzählen, die ihr bei der Wahl abgibt. Das ist jetzt im Folgenden nicht ganz korrekt, weil wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde darüber gesprochen, was eigentlich stattfindet, also wie Stimmen ausgezählt werden, an welchen Punkten das Software zum Einsatz kommt. Es gibt eine bestimmte Software, nämlich PC-Wahl, die in den letzten Wochen für Schlagzeilen gesorgt hat. Die wird bei uns gar nicht eingesetzt. Aber wo und was damit nicht stimmt und wie man überhaupt dazu kommt, das erklärt uns Martin Tschirsig. Hallo, willkommen zurück. So, also, wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde schon ganz aus Furcht darüber gesprochen, was eigentlich Wahlsoftware genau heißt. Jetzt würde ich gern wissen, du hast dir die ja genau angeguckt. Wie bist du überhaupt auf die Idee gekommen? Und dann, wie bist du überhaupt herangekommen?
Ja, das ist eigentlich auch schon die größte Hürde gewesen bei dieser ganzen, ich sag mal, Aufdeckungsgeschichte, an diese Software zu gelangen. Beziehungsweise überhaupt die Prozesse zu verstehen, die ablaufen, nachdem die Wahllokale die Daten telefonisch an das Wahlamt, an der Gemeinde transferiert haben. Das war gar nicht so leicht. Es war also meine Frage, die ich mir gestellt hatte eines Abends. Es gab ja schon lange die Berichte dazu entsprechen, dass die Bundestagswahl im Fokus steht, dass da sich jetzt technische Überlegungen getroffen werden, um diese Wahl abzusichern. Da hatte ich mir die Gedanken dazu gemacht, wie das hier eigentlich aussieht, was passiert, nachdem wir unsere Stimme abgegeben haben. Da ist ja kein großes Potenzial, die Wahl an sich zu verfälschen. Wahlcomputer werden bei der Bundestagswahl praktisch momentan nicht eingesetzt. Gut, was passiert dann? Ist da Potenzial? Wie werden diese Stimmen aggregiert? Wie kriegen wir so schnell Ergebnisse? Und da ich in Hessen wohne, habe ich mir das in Hessen angeschaut. Und in Hessen wird das Programm, wie ich dann rausgefunden habe, PC-Wahl eingesetzt. Das war einfach eine erweiterte Internetrecherche mit den Schlagworten Wahlauswertung oder Wahl Hessen Bundestagswahl-Wahlsoftware. So ist eine Richtung. Gibt es da Software, gibt es da Computerprogramme, die laufen. Und das führte dann direkt zum kommunalen IT-Nienstleister in Hessen. Das ist in dem Fall die ECOM21. Die ist dafür zuständig, die Infrastruktur bereitzustellen und die Software zu verteilen an die Gemeinden, an die Wahlämter, die zur Auswertung der Wahl am Wahlabend eingesetzt wird und auch danach. Und daraus ging hervor, dass es in Hessen zumindest für jeden Wahlkreis vorbereitete sogenannte Versanddateien, Versandprojekte gibt. In diesen Dateien, die waren auf der Seite des kommunalen IT-Dienstleisters öffentlich abrufbar, stehen dann auch Zugangsdaten und da lässt sich schon herauslesen, wie dieser Datentransfer funktioniert am Wahlabend von den Gemeinden zur Kreisebene. Und als ich diese Daten dann nach dieser Google-Suche in den Händen gehalten hatte, da wurde mir ein bisschen klar, okay, es kommt tatsächlich Software zum Einsatz, um unsere ausgezählten Stimmen aus den Wahllokalen zu übertragen, auf die nächste Ebene des Kreises zu transferieren, um die zu akkumulieren. Und da hab ich mir schon Gedanken gemacht, okay, wenn diese Software, die war dann noch nicht, hatte ich noch nicht gesehen, gehabt, kannte ich noch nicht, weil es noch nicht funktioniert, wenn die geheim ist, aber die Zugangsdaten für diese Übertragungswege im Netz öffentlich herunterladbar sind von diesem IT-Dienstleister, dann schien mir das merkwürdig, also das schien mir eine Sicherheitslücke zu sein. Da hatte ich dann Kontakt aufgenommen mit der Econ, das heißt sogar direkt mit dem, habe ich dann eine Verbindung hergestellt bekommen, mit dem Entwickler und Programmierer dieser Wahlsozial-PC-Wahl und der hatte mir dann, das war schon noch am selben Abend, direkt beschreinigt, ja tatsächlich, hier werden am Wahlabend Schnellmeldungsergebnisse übertragen an den Wahlkreis und ja tatsächlich, das sind die Tools-Daten dazu und damit könnte man die Daten auch ändern. Dann gab es dieses Zitat, damit kann man am Wahlabend Verwirrung stiften.
Stopp halt. Ich möchte jetzt kurz, also du hast dir das Ganze angeguckt und hast dann sozusagen erstmal den Weg nachgeprüft, in die Daten gehen.
Ja, richtig.
Und hast herausgefunden, wie man an die Daten rankommt und sie theoretisch ändern könnte.
Erstmal wusste ich noch gar nicht, was ich da in Hand hatte. Ich hatte quasi auch keine Vorstellung, was überhaupt passiert, ob es da Übertragungswege gibt, wie das überhaupt abläuft. Ich hatte nur Daten gefunden, sogenannte Versandprojekte, in denen Zugangsdaten drin standen, zu einem FDP-Server ganz konkret, auf dem Wahldaten übertragen werden. Und da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, was auch immer da übertragen wird, Wahldaten werden übertragen, Stimmergebnisse werden übertragen, FDP-Server und hier stehen Zugangsdaten davon im Netz, öffentlich. Das hat sich erst mal für mich nicht richtig angehört. Und dann hatte ich den Entwickler kontaktiert und der hatte mir dann die Aussage gemacht, mit diesen Daten, die ich da gefunden hab, kann ich am Wahlabend Verwiderungen stiften, in denen ich Wahlergebnisse, die übertragen werden, akkumuliert werden für Fälsche. Und dann hat bei mir, hat es sozusagen, da sind bei mir die Lichter angegangen und ich hab gedacht, nee, das kann doch nicht sein.
Also die Aussage zu dem Zeitpunkt war, okay, diese Daten werden übertragen und du könntest da theoretisch ran und die auch irgendwie ändern, aber weil es ja im Endergebnis sozusagen diesen analogen Prozess gibt, wäre das, ich sage nur in ganz großen Anführungszeichen, nur Verwirrung.
Ja, so war das die Aussage, die ich da gehört hatte. Und ich hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht die Software. Ich wusste nicht, was noch alles passiert. Ich hatte nur diese Aussage und das hat sich für mich schon so angehört, als sollte das nicht so sein. Also quasi das war der Grund, warum ich dann überhaupt eingestiegen bin und dann mal geforscht habe, ob es denn diese Software überhaupt quasi öffentlich gibt, ob man dazu was lesen kann, ob man irgendwie erfahren kann als Bürger, wie unsere Ergebnisse verarbeitet werden und wie das dann aussieht, welche Software zum Einsatz kommt und so weiter.
Und dann bist du sozusagen auf die PC-Wahl-Software gestoßen. Hast du die auch organisiert?
Als erstes hatte ich dazu im Netz tatsächlich von einem anderen, dem Herrn Ingo Höft, damals Wahlhälfer, Piratenpolitiker, dazu von ihm auf einem Blog gelesen, wie er schon, ich meine 2009, versucht hat, diese Wahlsoftware einzusehen. Hat er eine Kommunikation veröffentlicht mit den Gemeinden, auch mit der Herstellerfirme.
Warte mal, wenn du einzusehen meinst, heißt das dann sozusagen, der wollte sich einfach mal angucken, wie die Software funktioniert oder der wollte den Punkt, den Punkt, okay.
Er wollte die Software einfach mal testen, mal schauen, ob die auch richtig funktioniert. Er wollte die sich mal ansehen, also anfühlen. Vielleicht wollte er auch den Quake-Code gerne einsehen. Aber als nächstes, als erstes wollte er überhaupt erst mal die Software einfach mal nachprüfen, um als Bürger zu sehen, ob da auch alles so richtig läuft mit so einer Stimmakkumulation. Und der ist gescheitert. Da gab es dann Urteile, die sein Anliegen negativ beschieden haben. Gesagt wurde, nee, das ist ein privates Produkt einer privaten Firma. Und die kann er gerne kontaktieren. Aber wir können das nicht öffentlich rausgeben, diese Software. Und da habe ich mir noch mal diese Herstellerfirma angeschaut von PC-Wahl. Das ist inzwischen die VoteIT GmbH. Die VoteIT GmbH war damals hervorgegangen 2016 aus dem Zusammenschluss von zwei Anbietern. Regio IT, deren Wahlsoftware sparte. Und die Berninger Software GmbH wurden zusammengeschlossen.
Ich glaube sozusagen, das komplette Firmengeflecht aufzudecken, würde jetzt ein bisschen zu weit führen. Ich würde gerne sozusagen zu dem Punkt kommen, wo du diese Software in den Händen gehalten hast und was du dann entdeckt hast.
Wie gesagt, ich bin auf deren Server, hatte ich mir angeschaut, von dieser Herstellung, von der Firma, als wir das Geflecht durchstochen. Und dann tatsächlich auf diesem Server, ja, ich glaube, man muss da eine gewisse URL eingeben. Teilweise waren auch Passwörter veröffentlicht von dem Servicebereich dieser Firma. Die lagen auch öffentlich im Netz auf diversen Webseiten veröffentlicht von irgendwelchen Gemeinden. Und mit diesem Zugangsdaten zu diesem Servicebereich von dieser Firma, konnte man sich Updates für die Software herunterladen. Und aus diesen Updates konnte man die originale Software rekonstruieren. So bin ich an diese Software gekommen und hatte die Daten recht bald. Das war keine große Hürde. Bei mir laufen gehabt.
Dann das ist vielleicht sozusagen für technische Dimension und Hacker nicht die erste Frage. Aber wie sah die aus?
Das ist ein in Delphi geschriebene Software, die unter Windows läuft und recht altbacken aussieht, weil sie ihre Wurzeln schon vor 30 Jahren gelegt bekam vom Hersteller. Wurde immer geupdatet, aber ist halt sehr alte Windows Software. Läuft lokal installiert auf den PCs.
Oder lass mich die Frage anders stellen. Du machst diese Software auf, hast dafür vielleicht kein Handbuch, weil du sie organisiert hast. Hast du genau verstanden, was man da wie machen muss? Oder musstest du die Idee erarbeiten, wie die funktioniert?
Nein, also wie gesagt, das ist sehr kompliziert, dieses Programm zu verstehen. Das war gar nicht so leicht. Man hat sich danach nach der Information geangelt aus dem Netz. Gab es hier mal eine Anleitung dazu, da noch mal eine Anleitung. Dann konnte man noch ein FTP-Modul installieren, Netzmodul und so weiter und so fort. Und nach und nach hat sich dann ein Gesamtbild ergeben. Besonders auch, wie diese Prozesse ablaufen mit der Software zusammen. Also, was genau passiert, wie diese Software eingesetzt wird, wie das im Wahlamt aussieht, wie das auf der Kreise eben aussieht. Ich hatte dann das Glück, dass ich auch mit einem Gemeindewahrleiter reden konnte und er mir demonstriert hat, wie diese Software bei ihm zum Einsatz kommt. Und er hat mir dann gezeigt, wie diese Software bei sich öffnet, die Eingabemaske, dann die Schnellmeldung eintippt am Wahlabend und dann die Ergebnisse abschickt.
Jetzt könnte man sagen, die ist irgendwie altbar, um die zu verstehen, aber sie könnte ja trotzdem sicher sein. Also mal davon abgesehen, dass der Übertragungsweg schon nicht ganz koscher ist, wie wir schon gehört haben. Aber hast du da dann noch irgendwas entdeckt, also bei der Software selber?
Ja, also die Software, die ich mir da angesehen hatte, war tatsächlich nicht ohne die Sicherheit. Also es gab eine Art Verschlüsselung der Daten. Auch die Zugangsdaten waren, ich sag mal, verschleiert, aber nicht verschlüsselt. Aber sobald man die Software in der Hand hatte, fiel das gesamte Sicherheitskonzept, brach das quasi zusammen. Man hat hier auf die sogenannte Security-by-Obscurity-Konzept gesetzt. Das heißt, man hat gesagt, wir halten diese Software geheim. Und solange niemand diese Software kennt, wird es auch gar nicht verstehen, was diese Daten bedeuten und kann dann auch nichts manipulieren.
Aber die, wie soll ich das sagen, also der Punkt, also als Laie jetzt sozusagen, ist mein Status, es gibt diese Software, aber die läuft ja nur bei den Leuten, die mit der Stimmeauszählung beschäftigt sind. Und wenn die böswillig sind, dann hab ich ja sowieso verloren, egal wie sicher die Software ist. Hatte die Software auch sozusagen, bietet die auch Angriffsmöglichkeiten von außen?
Richtig, das ist nämlich genau die Frage, die ich mir dann gestellt hatte. Man ging immer davon aus, dass diese Software an sich sicher ist, dass sie funktioniert, dass der Softwareanbieter traurig ist und auch die richtige Software bereitstellt. Und genau da bieten sich wirklich sehr große Lücken in dem Sicherheitskonzept. Es war sehr klar und sehr schnell ersichtlich, dass zum Beispiel diese automatischen Updates für diese Software mit der Software auf alle Wahlämter auf die Computer eingespielt werden kann, die diese Software einsetzen. Diese automatischen Updates sind angreifbar und ich kann oder ein Angreifer hätte eigene Software platzieren können als Update und verteilen können automatisch an die Wahlämter, die diese Software einsetzen. Das wäre ein möglicher Angriffsweg gewesen. Es gab dann auch noch die Möglichkeit.
Ich will kurz erklären sozusagen für Menschen, die nicht genau wissen, wie das funktioniert. Also Software Update, das heißt manchmal ist es ja so, wenn ihr euren Rechner anmacht, bei Windows häufiger als bei anderen Systemen erscheint diese Meldung so, ich lade mir jetzt ein Update runter. Und was der Computer dann macht ist, er geht von alleine auf einen anderen Server und holt sich dort Programmcode oder sozusagen Programme und installiert die selbstständig. Und es gibt normalerweise Technologien, die sicherstellen, dass da genau das runtergeladen wird, was es auch vorgibt zu sein. Also dass sozusagen, wenn das Update zu einem Rechner kommt, dass es tatsächlich ein Update vom Hersteller der Software ist und nicht von irgendjemand. Und du sagst jetzt genau dieses System wurde unterlaufen. Das heißt, der Wahlprogramm Benutzer macht die Software. Und das ist in Wirklichkeit aber von jemand, der da Schadcode eingeschleust hat.
Genau, richtig. Das wurde auch live demonstriert. Einmal von CCC, Torsten Schröder und Linus Neumann haben dann sich diese Software auch nochmal angeschaut. Haben dazu auch einen detaillierten Bericht im Netz veröffentlicht. Analyse dieser Wahlsoftware. Und haben diesen Angriff auch einmal live demonstriert. Natürlich in einer Demo-Umgebung, dass man tatsächlich eigene Software verteilen könnte. Es gab dann auch die andere Angriffsmöglichkeit, nicht auf die Software an sich, sondern auf die Übertragungskanäle. Wir haben vorhin schon gehört, dass das auch per E-Mail teilweise getragen wird. Das Wahlergebnis. Die Übertragung per Dateitransferprotokoll, die hier eingesetzt wurde bei dieser speziellen Software, war auch unsicher. Da kamen dann auch mehrere Umstände zusammen, dass der IT-Dienstleister in Hessen für die Infrastruktur, die hier zum Einsatz kommt, sehr schwache Passwörter gewählt hatte. Das waren Passwörter Test, Test, Test 1 und so weiter.
Mit Infrastruktur meinst du, die Rechner, die dafür benutzt werden, um die Daten zwischen den verschiedenen Ebenen zu übertragen?
Richtig. Also diese Daten, diese Ergebnisse dieser Software, die werden, also diese Wahldaten, werden in gewissen Netzen übertragen. Das ist nicht immer das öffentliche Internet. Das sind teilweise private Netzwerke. Die sind mit einem Passwort geschützt von außen. Und diese Passwörter, da wurden grundlegende Regeln eben auch missachtet, die auch diesen Schutz, man hätte ja sagen können, die Software ist unsicher, aber wir sperren jeden Angreifer aus, indem wir diese Software auf unseren eigenen privaten Netzen benutzen. Eben nicht öffentlich. Auch dieser Schutz hat nicht gewirkt, weil auch hier keine Sicherheitsstandards eingehalten wurden. Also es gab dann noch weitere Angriffswege, es gab wirklich mehrere, die auch alle dann an den Hersteller gemeldet wurden. Und dann hatte der Hersteller, ich glaube seit Juni, Informationen über diese Schwachstellen und hat dann versucht, diese Schwachstellen zu beheben. Die Wahl rückte dann mehr und es hat nicht geklappt. Es gab dann noch mal eine weitere Analyse zu den Korrekturversuchen und die war also bis zum Ende unsicher, die Software. Die wurde dann am Ende quasi, wurden diese automatischen Updates komplett abgeschaltet. Und dann hat man gesagt, gut, wir machen das ganz geheim. Wir verteilen neue Software noch über den IT-Dienstleister, über Personen, die wir kennen sozusagen.
Also ein Bote mit dem USB-Stick quasi.
Ja, also ähnlich, wie man sich das vorstellt. Und wir vertrauen einfach darauf, dass die Netze, in denen wir diese Software betreiben, dass die nicht angegriffen werden von außen.
Natürlich nicht, das wird der Werte daran ein Interesse.
Also die Software an sich wurde nicht sicherer gemacht. Man hat einfach noch mal quasi die Sicherheitsstandards erhöht, der Infrastruktur, also der Netze, in denen die Software betrieben wird.
Okay, also das heißt sozusagen besser, aber noch weit entfernt davon gut zu sein.
Richtig, genau. Vor allen Dingen wurde auch weiterhin nicht offengelegt, wie diese Software funktioniert. Und wir wissen auch nicht, wie sie inzwischen, also wie das letzte Update aussah. Das können wir oder auch der CCC nicht beurteilen, weil das auch nicht mehr öffentlich gemacht wird.
Jetzt habe ich noch eine Frage in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Hast du jemals danach noch irgendwie Kontakt mit dem Hersteller der Software gehabt? Und was sagt der eigentlich dazu?
Direkt nicht, aber er hat sich gegenüber der Zeit zum Beispiel geäußert. Der Herr Kai Biermann von der Zeit hat ihn interviewt. Und seine Aussage, also die Aussage des Entwicklers, das quasi ein Ein-Mann-Unternehmen gewesen, dass diese Software entwickelt hat, war, ja, die Software bietet hier halt Ankunftsmöglichkeiten, also paraphrasiert. Wurde allerdings auch nie gefordert, dass die Software sicher ist. Das haben die Gemeinden nie verlangt. Von daher wurde das auch nie umgesetzt.
Okay, also ich möchte das nur mal in meinen Worten zusammenfassen. Es gibt also den Typen, der Software dafür gebaut hat, dass eines der demokratischen, fast schon super Grundrechte ausgezählt wird und der hatte nicht von alleine die Motivation und den Antrieb zu sagen, diese Software muss das verdammt sicherste Stück Software sein, das ich jemals in meinem Leben schreiben werde.
Nein, das lag auch daran, dass diese Software eben über 30 Jahre gewachsen ist. Und in der Zeit, in der die Architektur oder diese Grundlagen genäht wurden, gab es ja noch keine.
Also ich meine, ist es zu viel verlangt von einem Programmierer, deinen eigenen Antrieb zu haben?
Natürlich nicht. Also es gibt hier auf vielen Seiten Versäumnisse. Unter anderem hätte auch der Hersteller ganz klar sehen können, dass hier ein Problem vorliegt. Ich meine, der kennt sich ja mit der Wahl nun am besten aus und weiß, wie das abläuft. Also von der Seite hätte auf jeden Fall etwas kommen müssen. Aber auch von den Gemeinden und auch von den Wahlleitern gibt es Versäumnisse, die eben nicht geschaut haben, ob diese Software an sich sicher ist. Die haben nur geprüft, adiert diese Software die Stimme richtig. Ja, das tut sie in den meisten Fällen. Also das wurde halt durch Tests evaluiert. Aber die Sicherheit der Software und die.
Übertragungswege, die wurde nie geprüft. Und das hätte nicht nur vom Hersteller, das hätte auch von den Wahlleitern kommen müssen, diese Anforderungen. Also da gab es auf vielen Seiten, gab es hier Versäumnisse. Ich möchte die vergangene Stunde mal mit zwei Worten zusammenfassen. Holy shit. Wir wollen gleich nochmal oder sozusagen will ich mit dir Martin und den Studiogästen hier über die sozusagen praktischen Konsequenzen darüber nochmal genauer sprechen und dann kommen wir vielleicht zu dem Punkt, wo wir sagen, okay, wie können wir das, also nicht diese spezielle Software, sondern so im Allgemeinen vielleicht diesen ganzen Vorgang, da wird Software für Wahlen benutzt, wie können wir das vielleicht besser machen? Dazu kommen wir gleich. Vorher gibt es ein kleines Stück Musik von Proraider nochmal. Der Track heißt jetzt Circus. Und damit ist Halbzeit im Chaos Radio bei Fritz im Blue Moon, wo wir heute über die Software sprechen, die unsere Stimme bei den Wahlen auszählt. Und wir haben gerade gehört, dass es da eine Software gibt, die nicht bei uns angewendet wird, sondern in Hessen PC-Wahl, die ziemlich viele Löcher hat und nicht so gut ist, fasse ich jetzt mal ganz diplomatisch die letzte Stunde zusammen. Und wir machen die Runde jetzt wieder ein bisschen größer. Ich begrüße nochmal Martin, der das alles entdeckt hat, am Telefon. Hallo, guten Abend. Und Danimo? So, wir haben jetzt sozusagen ganz viel über diese PC-Wahl-Software gehört. Wenn ihr aufmerksam die Berlin-Wahl verfolgt habt, da gab es anscheinend auch einen kleinen Schluck auf zur Bundestagswahl, weil da so vorläufige Ergebnisse nicht rechtzeitig genug kommen. Und ich habe den Herrn Danimo gebeten, nochmal genauer nachzulesen, was da genau passiert ist. Bitte schön. Genau, also es war tatsächlich so, ich habe am Anfang ein wenig geflunkert. Diese Schnellmeldung ging nämlich so richtig schnell raus. Zumindest in Berlin. Denn das ITTZ, also der IT-Dienstleister des Landes Berlin, hatte da ein nicht näher genanntes Problem. Also tatsächlich, ich habe mich nochmal eingelesen, die grobe Aussage war einfach nur, wir haben das vorher unter realistischen Bedingungen durchgespielt. Da hat alles geklappt und jetzt hat es halt nicht mehr geklappt. Das heißt, wir wissen nur, die haben da auch eine Software benutzt und die hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert? Genau. Das ist ja sehr beruhigend. Das ist total beruhigend. Und dann habe ich hier noch den Hinweis gefunden, es gäbe 12 verschiedene Systeme in Berlin zur Datenübermittlung an das Amt für Statistik, die nicht optimal aufeinander eingestellt seien. Man arbeite aber an einer gemeinsamen IT-Infrastruktur. Es gibt auch noch andere Wahlen. Es ist ja nicht nur Bundestagswahl. Jetzt ist aber bei dem Schluckauf auch so, dass der nur das vorläufige Ergebnis verzögert hat, ne? Genau. Also letztendlich musste man, wenn man sich die Hochrechnungen angeguckt hat am Abend, dann bedeutet das, dass das, was man aus Berlin gesehen hat, tatsächlich nur aus den Exit-Polls, also den Befragungen aus dem Wahllokal genommen wurden. Und die echten Zahlen erst im Laufe der Nacht geliefert wurden. Da war es tatsächlich so, dass da Booten durch die Stadt geschickt wurden mit den Schnell-Ergebnissen. Es lohnt immer noch, reiten zu lernen, Leute. Das ist schon der zweite Boot. Der eine mit den Wahlergebnissen, der andere mit den USB-Sticks für die Software-Updates. Es lohnt sich. Aber jetzt stelle ich mir die Frage. Wir haben in der letzten Stunde gelernt, okay, das mit der Software, das ist suboptimal. Aber wir haben auch gelernt, das eigentliche Endergebnis ist halt immer noch diese, wie heißt das nochmal, Wahlniederschrift? Genau. Genau, die Wahlniederschrift. Also das heißt, das ist relativ sicher. Die wird also versiegelt und eingereicht. Ja, also wir können sozusagen zumindest für die theoretische Diskussion heute noch davon ausgehen, das Ergebnis ist okay. Und sagen, nur die vorläufigen Ergebnisse, also nur in Anführungszeichen. Darauf würde ich gleich hinaus. Vorläufige Ergebnisse sind sozusagen möglicherweise beeinflussbar. Und jetzt würde mich tatsächlich eure Einschätzung oder Fantasie interessieren. Für wie hart, also praktisch, was praktisch der wirkliche Schaden sein könnte. Martin, du hast dich ja sozusagen total ausführlich mit dieser Software jetzt beschäftigt. Und mehrere Wochen lang. Worin siehst du denn jetzt, also mal abgesehen davon, dass das alles sehr bedenklich ist, dass genau an dieser Stelle sowas passiert, siehst du wirklich ganz konkrete Gefahren oder kannst du dir Szenarien ausmalen, wo das wirklich einen Schaden bringt?
Ja, durchaus. Die vorläufigen Ergebnisse stehen ja schon in der Wahlnacht fest. Und schon am nächsten Morgen sind ja dann entsprechende Artikel darüber geschrieben, beziehungsweise Reaktionen der entsprechenden wahrscheinlichen Fraktionsbildung oder der Parteien erfolgt, die sich dazu äußern zu dem Ergebnis. Zum Beispiel von Schulz kam ja schon die Aussage sehr bald, nachdem das Wahllokal verlassen hatte, dass die SPD in die Opposition gehen würde. Und all solche Aussagen fußen ja nicht auf den endgültigen Ergebnissen. Die endgültigen Ergebnisse sind erst für diese Wahl jetzt am 6. Oktober auf Bundesebene zu erwarten. Und bis dahin sind es ja noch eine Woche hin oder zwei. Das heißt, bis dahin vertrauen wir doch schon darauf, dass diese angeblich vorläufigen Ergebnisse richtig sind. Wenn jetzt diese Ergebnisse fehlst werden, wird das natürlich recht bald auffallen. Es wird dann von Wahlhilfern beispielsweise Einsprüche geben. Zum Beispiel am nächsten Morgen werden die dann sehen, das stimmt nicht mit dem überein, was ich damals nach 18 Uhr in die Wahlniederschrift eingetragen hab. Und dann wird dann irgendwann am Tag danach oder zwei, bei einer großläufigen Erfolgmanipulation immer mehr derartige Berichte werden dann auftauchen, dass die Wahlergebnisse hier falsch sind, dass die dann nicht korrigiert werden. Und auf einmal ergibt sich dann ein komplett anderes Bild. Und dann ist das Vertrauen natürlich weg. Dann fragt man sich, okay, jetzt haben wir die Wahlergebnisse, Update 2.0, welches Update oder wann kommen denn die richtigen Ergebnisse? Und ja, das ist die größte Gefahr, die ich hier sehe.
Das heißt aber auch zu sagen, wenn man so einen Angriff starten würde, als Angriffsperspektiv, dann würde man nicht irgendwie ein paar Wahlergebnisse ganz krass ändern, sondern man würde dafür sorgen, dass ganz viele Wahlergebnisse sich ein bisschen ändern, damit es sozusagen möglichst schlecht auffällt. Oder wie wäre das?
Also aus meiner Fantasie, ich bin jetzt ein Wahlfälscher, würde ich das so sehen. Die Digitalisierung erlaubt uns ja hier, dass wir durch einen Eingriff zum Beispiel beim Hersteller über diesen Update-Mechanismus oder Angreifen von Landesinfrastruktur, dass wir da großflächige Ergebnisse manipulieren können. Und diese großflächige Manipulation ist ja die Gefahr. Ohne Wahlsoftware könnte man hier und da fälschen, wenn man einen Insider hätte in den Wahlämtern. Aber großflächig wäre das nicht möglich. Hiermit haben wir die Möglichkeit, großflächig Dinge zu manipulieren. Und das ist die Gefahr. Dass dann Ergebnisse großflächig auch so verfälscht werden, dass diese Manipulation dann auch für großflächige Verwirrung sorgt.
Okay, aber du hast auch gesagt, das Endergebnis kommt ja erst am 6. Oktober. Aber es ist schon wahrscheinlich, dass die Fälschungen früher auffallen würden. Also, je krasser sie sind, desto schneller würden sie wahrscheinlich gehen.
Ich denke, meine persönliche Einschätzung, wo ich die größte Gefahr sehe, ist, dass das Vertrauen in diesen Wahlprozess verloren geht. Ein erfolgreicher Angriff wäre einer, bei dem die Manipulation auch aufgedeckt würde. Also ich sehe es so, dass jemand, der demokratische Strukturen angreifen möchte, die demokratische Legitimation, die es diese Wahlen gibt, angreifen möchte, das Fundament unserer Regierung schwächen möchte, dass derjenige auch will, dass diese Manipulation bekannt wird. Denn wenn eine Manipulation nicht bekannt wird, würde sich auch keiner darüber Gedanken machen. Wenn sie bekannt wird, dann ist auf einmal dieser Vertrauen hoch.
Also das realistische Szenario ist für dich gar nicht, so zu sagen, okay, Partei XY bekommt jetzt irgendwie 5% mehr zu Geschussert. Sondern das realistische Szenario ist für dich, da schafft es jemand, das generelle Vertrauen in die Wahl zu erschüttern, was dann dazu führen würde, dass die beste Lösung eine neue Wahl wäre.
Zum Beispiel. Oder dass zumindest dieser ganze Prozess mehr und mehr in Frage steht, ob man jetzt endlich darauf vertrauen kann, ob das so richtig ist. Und das ist, meiner Meinung nach, das wichtigste Gut, was hier angegriffen werden kann.
Genau. Also wir hatten auch ohne Wahlsoftware aber einfach dieser chaotischen Situation hier in Berlin geschuldet, tatsächlich einen Fall, nämlich in Charlottenburg-Wilmersdorf, wo es erst so aussah, als hätte der SPD-Kandidat das Rennen gemacht. Und dann stellte sich dann doch später raus, dass der CDU-Kandidat dann letztendlich der Gewinner war. In dem Fall haben sie wahrscheinlich nur auf der falschen Seite zu früh den Champagner aufgemacht. Das ist ein überschaubarer Schaden, zumal das in der Nacht lief. Aber wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, dass diese Ergebnisse etwas persistenter, also langwieriger sind und es erst später auffällt, also Tage später wirklich. Also hier ist es ja direkt aufgefallen, weil man gemerkt hat, okay, diese Daten sind nicht plausibel offensichtlich. Aber wenn die plausibel wären. Man muss ja in diesem Fall ja auch sagen, da war zu jedem Zeitpunkt klar, der liegt zwar knapp vorne, das sind aber noch nicht die aktuellen Ente- Genau, man neigt ja zum frühen Feiern, aber jedem war eigentlich klar, dass das unter Umständen noch nicht die Wahrheit ist.
Ja, du musst ja auch ganz klar sehen, du kannst damit wirklich eine Partei kaputt rocken. Stell dir das mal vor, am Wahlamt sieht es anders aus, als es tatsächlich ist. Dann werden Rücktritte natürlich ausgesprochen. Du kannst ja schlecht sagen, wenn es jetzt 5% mehr ist, dann trete ich doch nicht zurück. Und alle anderen, die sich schon positiv oder negativ über diesen Rücktritt geäußert haben, da sieht es natürlich ähnlich aus. Ähnlich sieht es natürlich auch aus mit möglichen Koalitionsaussagen oder Absagen. Wenn sich jetzt diverse Parteien hinstellen und sagen, das hätten wir uns eh nicht vorstellen können, dann stiftet das unglaublich viel Chaos. Das wird nicht nur eine Partei, sondern ziemlich viele Parteien durcheinander werfen. Was mir tatsächlich die größte Sorge macht, und das wurde ja auch angesprochen, ist dieser Vertrauensverlust. Wir erinnern uns alle an die Wahl in den USA, in denen Trump schon vorher vor Wahlfälschung gewarnt hat und noch mal neu auszählen wollte. Als er ihn gewonnen hatte, wollte er ihn dann doch nicht neu auszählen. Und ein ähnliches Muster erleben wir ja auch bei rechten Parteien in Deutschland. Die AfD hat vor allen Landtagswahlen in Deutschland vor Wahlfälschung gewarnt. Und das ist natürlich auch ein beliebtes Mittel, wenn einem die Ergebnisse nicht passen, zu sagen, so ja, das liegt auf jeden Fall an Manipulation. Und wenn es tatsächlich einen Fall von Manipulation gibt, spielt das natürlich denjenigen in die Hände, die die grundsätzliche Legitimation durch Wahlen absprechen, indem sie behaupten, ja, das wird alles nicht richtig zusammengezählt, das geht nicht mit rechten Dingen zu.
Elisabeth, hast du auch noch Dinge?
Auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, dass tatsächlich der Vertrauensbruch auch nicht nur dort eintritt, wenn gerade Wahlen stattfinden, sondern wir hoffen ja, dass wenn die Regierung oder Ministerien oder generell auch irgendwelche Stellen irgendwelche Informationen bereitstellen oder zu Dingen aufrufen, dass das mit fundierter Basis passiert, dass die Leute sehr gut informiert sind.
Und wenn einmal ein Präzedenzfall eintritt, wo Informationen bereitgestellt werden, die angegriffen wurden, die nicht korrekt sind, dann denke ich, dass sich das auch auf andere Bereiche überträgt, dass da Vertrauen stark verloren geht.
Also das heißt, technisch gesehen ist es tatsächlich nur das Vorläufergebnis, aber praktisch kann das sozusagen eine ganz krasse Auswirkung haben. Jetzt ist, Martin hatte das währenddessen schon immer wieder gesagt, also oder andersrum. Es gibt ja sozusagen anscheinend ne, noch andersrum. Also das Wichtigste ist ja, dass so eine Software zuverlässig funktioniert. Jetzt klingt aber immer wieder an, na ja, aber die wird ja versteckt. Jetzt gibt es dieses Konzept von Open Source. Kann das nochmal jemand ganz kurz erklären, warum das wichtig ist und wie das funktioniert und vor allen Dingen, wie das dann in diesem Fall funktionieren würde?
Ja, also Open Source kann man sich ein bisschen so vorstellen, wenn man sich Software als eine Box vorstellt, wo ich irgendwas reinwerfe und da kommt irgendwas raus. Dann ist eine Software, bei der ich nicht den Quellcode einsehen kann, so ein bisschen wie eine Blackbox. Ich werfe was rein und dann sehe ich, ok, da passiert irgendwas, da wird irgendwas mit dem Gegenstand gemacht und da fällt ein anderer Gegenstand raus. Aber wie das Ganze funktioniert innerhalb dieser Box, das muss ich dann raten. Das kann ich vielleicht dann über unterschiedliche Tests versuchen, rauszufinden, Reverse Engineering nennt sich das dann, aber im Endeffekt muss ich dann doch raten. Und offener Source Code bedeutet, dass jeder in den Maschinenquot einer Software reingucken kann. Das heißt, jeder kann jederzeit reingucken und sagen, aha, so funktioniert das und das macht es tatsächlich sehr viel einfacher, Fehler zu finden oder auch wenn etwas hakt, wenn unterschiedliche Programme zusammenspielen, zu sagen, wo der Fehler beispielsweise liegt. Und im Fall der Wahlauswertungssoftware, der würde offener Southcore bedeuten, dass man beispielsweise öffentlich im Netz sich jeder die Software runterladen kann. Also das ist quasi ein gegenteiliges Sicherheitskonzept, statt die Software zu verstecken. Sagt man, guckt doch alle rein. Und wenn ihr was findet, dann sagt Bescheid. Und das bedeutet eben auch, dass man kennt das ja bei vielen Prinzipien, vier Augen sehen mehr als zwei. Im Fall der Software war es ja tatsächlich nur ein Typ. Und da hat man eben eine größere Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Fehler entdeckt werden und auch ausgebessert werden.
Aber jetzt dieses Konzept sozusagen, also Computerexperten, Programmierer, müssten sie da doch einig sein, oder? Also die Erklärung ist ja relativ einleuchtend. Ich sehe die Technik, die da innen drin vorgeht, dann kann ich auch beurteilen, ob das funktioniert oder nicht. Und gerade bei so einem Wahlergebnis ist es ja auch ganz sozusagen egal, ob ich das weiß, wie das funktioniert oder nicht, weil es ja eh transparent sein soll. Warum, also was ist die Begründung, die Leute sagen so, ne, wir wollen das aber nicht herzeigen?
Geld.
Das kann man recht...
Verschwinde ich nicht?
Das kann man recht eindeutig sagen. Also so, man nehme sich mal einen Vergleich. Also es gibt ja ein freies Betriebssystem mit offenem Quellcode, das nennt sich Linux. Oder man kann es, ja, es gibt ja auch unterschiedliche Ableger oder Distributionen, beispielsweise Ubuntu. Und da ist es so, jeder kann reingucken. Und dann gibt es Windows, und bei Windows ist es genau andersrum. Man kann eben nicht reingucken. Und der Hersteller argumentiert eben da auch sehr stark mit Gewinninteressen, dass man sagt, ich hab das Patent geschützt und ich möchte nicht, dass andere Leute das kopieren. Und deshalb verschleiere ich das lieber. Meine Box soll schön verklebt zu sein, da soll niemand reingucken, weil sonst kauft ja niemand mehr das Produkt. Sonst kann sich das jeder einfach kopieren. Und das finde ich ist ein grundsätzlich erst mal hinterfragenswürdiges Konzept. Denn wenn man sich mal anguckt, was für eine Software auf den meisten Supercomputern und Hochgeschwindigkeitsrechnern läuft, ist das eben nicht Windows, sondern Linux. Und wenn man sich mal anguckt, was eigentlich die Infrastruktur hinter den größten Diensten, die wir tagtäglich nutzen, ist. Ist auch freies Software.
Ich möchte das aber trotzdem unterbrechen, weil ich finde, der Vergleich hinkt ein bisschen. Weil die Software, die ich auf meinem Rechner benutze, das ist ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das noch umdrehen soll, aber das ist ja im Prinzip eine Dienstleistung, die ich bekomme. Das ist ja etwas, wo ich darauf angewiesen bin, dass es funktioniert und es für mich als Endnutzer zumindest gar nicht so wichtig ist, was da drin vorgeht. Also ist es natürlich auch, aber wie beim Auto, nehme ich das Ding halt und fahre damit, dann ist es mir letztlich egal. Während das bei den Wahlen was anderes ist. Das ist ja was Öffentliches. Das ist was, wo quasi auch mein Steuergeld drin ist. Und das ist was, wo ich viel eher darauf angewiesen bin, dass es transparent ist. Bei meinem Computer bin ich darauf angewiesen, dass es funktioniert. Ja, aber das ist, wenn du jetzt überlegst, wie sowas in der Praxis funktioniert. Ich habe eben schon gesagt, die eigentliche Technik wird von einem Dienstleister gemacht, der dem Land gehört. Und dieser Dienstleister macht letztendlich auch erst mal nichts anderes, genau wie du das privat tun würdest, und kauft Softwarelizenzen. Dass er das nicht tun muss, ist das eine. Aber das ist halt die Praxis. Und die sagen halt, ich möchte möglichst wenig damit zu tun haben. Ich möchte die Software betreiben, aber ich möchte nicht das Ding von Grund auf neu programmieren. So, das ist der Stand, mit dem sie argumentieren. Da haben wir natürlich noch andere Argumentationswege. Aber Stand heute ist die... Das verstehe ich nicht, das ist ja genau das Argument für meinen Blickwinkel. Weil wenn ich als Dienstleister sage, ich möchte nichts damit zu tun haben, wie dieser Betrieb funktioniert, dann kann ich ja antworten, so verkaufe mir also die Software und sorge dafür, dass sie funktioniert und mache auch deinen Codequell offen.
Ja klar, also das kann man ja über Ausschreibungen regeln. Da stehen ja dann unterschiedliche, sage ich mal, Faktoren drin. Beispielsweise darf maximal so und so teuer sein, muss diese Sicherheitsstandards erfüllen. Das wäre vielleicht auch mal eine Maßnahme. Und da kann man ohne Weiteres reinschreiben. Die Software muss anschließend unter einer freien Lizenz stehen. Was natürlich auch dazu führt, dass man weniger abhängig von einem Anbieter wird. Das heißt, wenn man einmal eine Software gekauft hat und der Code ist frei, da kann ich auch sagen, du hast nicht geliefert. Du hast, um es auf gut Deutsch zu sagen, richtig verkackt in diesem Fall sogar. Und dann gehe ich zu dem anderen.
Aber das ist der Geldpunkt. Also quasi, wenn ich dir eine Software verkaufe, wo du nicht weißt, was drin ist, dann bist du darauf angewiesen, die auch beim nächsten Mal zu benutzen, weil du dann entweder alles von vorne machen musst oder halt mich nochmal bezahlst, egal wie gut die Software funktioniert oder nicht, weil du sonst nicht an die Dinge rankommst, die du mitgemacht hast. Du kriegst auch nur von mir Wartung. Von niemand anderem. Verstehe. Okay, das wird beabsagt. So, jetzt seid ja Lisa und Katascha, ihr seid ja hier für das Schlagwort, ich hoffe, ich mach das richtig, Public Money, Public Code. So, jetzt machen wir zwei Sachen kurz in der Reihenfolge. Erstens, erklärt mal bitte dieses Motto, was das bedeutet. Und zweitens, Lisa, du kommst ja vom Prototype Fund, Katascha, du kommst von der Free Software Foundation Europe, erklärt dann mal, was für Organisationen das sind und was dein Ziel ist. So, was meint dieses Public Money, Public Code?
Ja, also die Free Software Foundation Europe setze ich eben für die Forderungen.
Nein, nein, du solltest jetzt erst erklären, was Public Money, Public Code ist.
Ach so, ja, also Public Money heißt öffentliche Gelder. Public Code heißt, ja, freier, oder Quell, freier Software Code oder quelloffener Software Code. Und die Idee ist eben, dass alles, was mit öffentlichen Geldern finanziert wird, insbesondere Software, die vom Scratch neu entwickelt wird, nur für diesen einen Zweck, für den staatlichen Zweck, dass es absolut nicht nachvollziehbar ist, warum das nicht immer unter eine freie Lizenz gestellt wird. Und das ist unsere Forderung. Und da haben wir uns eben überlegt, machen wir doch mal ein Bündnis.
Halt, halt, halt, stopp. Also erst mal nur. Public Money, Public Code bedeutet, das ist sozusagen ein politisches Konzept, das besagt, wenn aus öffentlichen Geldern Software finanziert ist, dann soll so die politische Forderung, der Quellcode auch öffentlich zugänglich und damit vor allen Dingen auch nachprüfbar sein.
Ja, weil es keinen Grund gibt, das nicht zu machen.
Okay, wir kommen zu den Details gleich noch. Was ist die Free Software Foundation Europe?
Ja, das ist ein Verein, auch ein gemeinnütziger Verein, der sich für die Förderung freier Software einsetzt. Das heißt, wir setzen uns dafür ein, dass in der Gesellschaft auch freie Software als öffentliches Gut oder als Gemeingut anerkannt wird. Wir setzen uns dafür ein, dass offene Standards genutzt werden, um eben Hürden für freie Software abzusenken und Leute auch dazu zu informieren, was die Vorteile sind und warum das geiler Scheiß ist.
Ok, also das Ziel ist Weltherrschaft wie immer, nämlich alles muss freie Software sein.
Wir haben uns dann strategisch überlegt, dass freie Software, siehe Wahlauswertungssoftware, ja schon ein wichtiger Schritt ist, um auch die Welt ein Stück besser zu machen.
Was ist der Prototype Fund?
Der Prototype Fund ist ein Förderprogramm, mit dem Softwareentwicklerinnen und Softwareentwickler in Deutschland sich mit Ideen oder schon bestehenden Projekten bewerben können und dann sechs Monate Zeit und Geld bekommen, um einfach mal diese Idee weiterzuentwickeln, auszutesten und eben danach auch den Code wieder zu releasen, freizugeben und damit andere damit weiterarbeiten können. Das ist ein Projekt der Opnolish Foundation Deutschland und ja, wir vergeben in halbjährlichen Abständen im Moment 47.500 Euro an kleine Teams und an Softwareentwickler.
Es gibt also die FSFE, die möchte, dass möglichst viel softwareoffenen Quellcode hat und es gibt den Prototype Fund, der sagt, wir geben euch Geld, aber nur wenn eure Software offenen Quellcode hat.
Genau, wir drehen das Motto quasi um, bei uns ist es Public Code, Public Money.
Gut, ihr habt mich doch abgesprochen. Oder ist das ein Zufall?
Kein Kommentar.
So, dann kommen wir dazu. Also quasi und jetzt wird es wird es so, die FSFE hat quasi die Vorlage oder versucht, die Motivation zu liefern. Und der Prototype Fund setzt das dann quasi um. Wie habt ihr es vorhin gesagt? Motivator und Enabler? So war das vorhin, habt ihr diese schöne Wortmeldung? Ja, da muss man ja auch ein bisschen bringen. Also neulich in der Chaosradio Sendung wurde ja irgendwie über Motivatorin und Enabler geredet. Das war wirklich sehr gut.
Ja, das eine ist dann Hands-on und das andere ist okay.
Okay, stopp, stopp, halt nicht so viel Bass zu veraberen, sonst fällt mir Sendung auseinander. So, was war die Idee der Kampagne, die ihr gemacht habt? Und vor allen Dingen, was hatte das dann noch zufälligerweise mit PC-Wahl zu tun?
Ja, also die Idee hat schon sehr lange in der Free Software Foundation gegärt. Es gab vor, ja, ich glaube mittlerweile fast zwei Jahren so ein Treffen von Freiwilligen und Fellows der Free Software Foundation, die sich überlegt haben, was sind denn so die Punkte, wo wir wirklich ansetzen müssen, um die Welt ein Stück besser zu machen. Und tatsächlich ist der Staat, wo staatliche Stellen sind, ein Riesenauftraggeber oder ein Riesenfaktor auf dem IT-Markt. Und es ist unglaublich, wie viel Software im Auftrag des Staates entwickelt wird, die auch für viele geile andere Zwecke genutzt werden könnte. Und wie viel Schindluder da auch getrieben wird, oder wie viel Unsicherheit da auch durch unfreie Software entsteht. Siehe Walauswertungssoftware. Und da ist eben die Idee entstanden zu Public Money, Public Code. Und wir haben gesagt, wir müssen die Gesetzgeber dazu motivieren oder darüber aufklären, warum es besser für sie ist, jegliche Software, die sie mit Steuergeldern finanzieren, unter eine freie Lizenz zu stellen. Ja, und dann haben wir sehr lange gebastelt, uns erstmal ins stille Kämmerlein zurückgezogen und haben dann eine Woche vor der Wahl einen offenen Brief veröffentlicht, in dem wir Regierung dazu auffordern. Gemeinsam mit vielen anderen Organisationen fordern wir das, dass das eben auch in den Gesetzgebungsprozess einfließt. Weil bei Ausschreibungen, also im Endeffekt müsste man das alles über Ausschreibungen klären. Und wenn in Ausschreibungen verbindlich geklärt ist, du kriegst den Auftrag nur, wenn der Code nachher freie Software ist, dann würden wir alle davon profitieren. Und das ist unglaublich abgehoben. Es gibt auch ein super Video dazu. Ihr könnt euch das angucken auf publiccode.eu. Und ja, mittlerweile haben über 11.000 Menschen, Individuen diesen offenen Brief unterzeichnet. Und sage und schreibe, 81 Organisationen haben sich der Forderung angeschlossen. Inklusive Edward Snowden.
Das ist ja gut und schön. Aber was sagt denn die Politik dazu? Oder sagt die überhaupt was dazu? Oder ist das so, ja ja, sammelt ihr mal schön eure Unterschriften, das ist uns egal.
Ja, also wenn man sich das global betrachtet, ist es tatsächlich unterschiedlich. In den USA ist es so, dass es, sag ich mal, ein öffentliches Code Repository schon gibt. Ja, das ist quasi wie ein online Verzeichnis. Da kann ich eintippen, ich suche Wahlauswertungssoftware und dann spuckt er mir hoffentlich aus von allen Bundesstaaten, wo es das gibt. Und die werden dazu angehalten, ihre Software, die unter freier Lizenz steht, auf so einem Tool hochzuladen, weil sie auch gesagt haben, naja, es gibt so viele unterschiedliche Programme, die in unterschiedlichen Bundesstaaten eingesetzt werden, ähnlich wie eben so eine Wahlauswertungssoftware im föderalen System in Deutschland. Da wäre es ja dumm, die Synergien nicht zu nutzen. Das heißt, warum soll jede Behörde immer alles von neu entwickeln, wenn sie sich doch bei einer anderen Behörde einfach bedienen würde? Das hat einfach auch Kosten und praktische Gründe. Und wenn die eine Behörde dann Geld über hat und dann noch ein Feature reinbaut, dann kann die andere davon ja auch profitieren.
Die sind also weiter als wir?
Die sind weiter als wir.
Wie ist es denn in Deutschland?
Also in Deutschland ist es leider ein bisschen traurig. Wir haben ganz viele Informationsfreiheitsanfragen gestellt an unterschiedliche Behörden. Die haben uns auch ein bisschen was geantwortet. Wie sie freie Software selbst einsetzen, aber nicht so viel zum Thema Ausschreibung. Wir haben da so einen riesigen Datensatz zurückbekommen, den wir erst noch auswerten müssen. Und da gibt es, also in Deutschland gibt es kein Gesetz, was es vorschreibt. Es gibt einzelne Inselprojektor, es gibt einzelne Behörden, die das sehr gut machen. Also es sind vor allem interessanterweise eher so geologische Fachinstitutionen, wo viele Nerds arbeiten, die wahrscheinlich noch aus dem Wissenschaftsbetrieb das kennen. Wir stehen alle auf den Schultern von Giganten.
Wie sieht es im Bereich Wahl aus?
Schlecht.
Aber du hast ja gerade gesagt, das Ding war in der Woche vor der Wahl. Da war ja gerade das mit PC-Wahl auch sozusagen in den Medien. War das jetzt sozusagen zufällig oder?
Wir haben natürlich im Geheimen darauf hingearbeitet. Nee, Spaß beiseite. Wir haben tatsächlich gesehen, okay, da passiert was. Und wir wollten auch unbedingt vor den Wahlen damit rausgehen, weil wir natürlich auch versuchen werden, jetzt in den Koalitionsverhandlungen nochmal Druck zu machen. Weil durch eine neue Regierung besteht ja auch die Chance, dass so etwas mal doch im Gesetzgebungsprozess fließt. Und ja, mit der Wahlauswertungssoftware, mit dem Hack hatten wir natürlich auch nochmal ganz andere Argumente auf der Tasche. Da wurde es halt viel plausibler nochmal, wie wichtig das alles eigentlich ist und wie gefährdet unsere öffentliche Infrastruktur ist. Weil es wird ja viel über kritische Infrastruktur gesprochen im Hinblick auf Straßen, Schienen, Elektrizität und so weiter. Und was man oft vergisst, ist, dass Software in immer mehr Bereichen eigentlich die kritische Infrastruktur ist. Und da ist es absolut unverständlich, warum man nicht den höchsten möglichen Sicherheitsstandard wahren will. Und das beinhaltet eben, dass es öffentlich sein muss. Damit man auch beispielsweise sieht keine Hintertüren von der NSA.
Aber jetzt, also ihr habt sozusagen ein theoretisch politisches Konzept gehabt. Und dann gleichzeitig noch sozusagen einen Fall, wo man sagt, haben wir euch nicht gesagt, dass es eine bessere Idee gewesen wäre, wenn? Gab es da mal irgendwie direkten Politikerkontakt? Weil das Ding ist ja so, das öffentlich zu fordern, einen offenen Brief irgendwie abzugeben, ist ja gut und schön. Aber gibt es überhaupt welche Schnittstellen, wo mal jemand persönlich damit konfrontiert wurde und der dann auch eine Reaktion dazu hatte? Ich halte es jetzt zu sagen, selbst wenn ich kein Fan von offener Software wäre, wäre das eine Stelle, wo ich sagen würde, okay, jetzt fällt es mir schon schwierig, eine Ausrede zu finden, warum es keine gute Idee sein soll.
Ja, wir hatten tatsächlich Feedback. Und zwar ungefähr zehn Unterzeichner unseres offenen Briefs sitzen jetzt im Bundestag. Und die Grünen haben auch nochmal mit einem offenen Brief geantwortet, worauf wir in den Koalitionsverhandlungen sicherlich nochmal zurückkommen werden. Und ja, es ist vielen Abgeordneten auch nochmal klarer geworden durch den Hack. Und wir werden in den nächsten Monaten viele Gespräche führen, haben dadurch glaube ich auch deutlich mehr Feedback bekommen.
Ich glaube, wenn ich hier noch einen Einschüpp gehen darf. Es wurde hier auch erstmal gezeigt, dass nicht öffentliche Software, also etwas, was sozusagen unter der Wahrnehmungsspelle fliegt, sowas wie Wahlsoftware, auch ein Sicherheitsrisiko darstellt. Deswegen wurde jetzt auch das BSI dazu eingeschaltet. Und das ist eine Neuentwicklung. Vorher, meine ich, lag der Fokus eben darauf, öffentliches Geld einzusetzen. Und jetzt geht es aber auch zusätzlich nach darum, dass man diesen Sicherheitsaspekt hat, wo öffentliche, also quelloffene Software auch überragend natürlich gewinnt gegenüber der proprietären, geheimen Software. Das heißt, mit diesem PC-Wahlhack, der weiß quasi so eine Art Warnschuss aus meiner Sicht, dass man hier die gefährliche Entwicklung festgestellt hat, dass immer mehr sehr basisdemokratische Prozesse nicht mehr nur software unterstützt wird, wo höchstens halt Geld verschwendet werden kann, sondern sie werden auch digital gestützt. Also man stützt sich komplett auf Software. Und genau da hat man eine Schwelle überschritten. Und genau da müsste man jetzt eigentlich nur einen Schritt zurücktreten und das nur evaluieren. Und ich hoffe, das findet jetzt noch statt. Und das war das aus den Gesprächen auch mit dem BSI herauszuhören.
Und man muss auch sagen, dass der CCC ja auch, sag ich mal, ich weiß nicht, ob man Glück sagen kann oder halt auch aufgrund seines Statuses in Deutschland auch sehr viel Vertrauen genießt. In Ungarn war es so, dass ein 18-jähriger eine Lücke im Budapester-System der Öffis quasi gefunden hat und das gemeldet hat. Und in Ungarn ist es aber so, dass es strafbar war, nach dem dortigen Gesetz Sicherheitslücken zu finden.
Okay, krass.
Und der wurde dann, also ja, dem drohte dann auch eine Strafe. Und wo man dann sagen muss, wir können doch nicht, sag ich mal, ein System dulden, wo jemand auch offiziell, also aktiv auf die Behörden zugeht und sagt, hier ist eine Fehlermeldung. Und das ist A, vom Betreiber gar nicht gewünscht offensichtlich. Und B, wird da gesetzlich auch noch mal oft ein Riegel vorgeschoben.
Richtig, das gab es auch hier bei dem PC-Wahlhack, wenn ich das einschieben darf.
Das müssen wir verschieben auf Nachdenachrichten, weil dafür ist jetzt gleich wieder Zeit. Und dann reden wir noch mal über, wie das war beim PC-Wahlhack, was es da sozusagen für Gefahren noch gab. Und reden auch noch mal über den Prototype-Fund. Vorher aber wie gesagt die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Live in der Kolumbiale. Faber.
Wann genau und wo genau?
Live von neu und gut empfohlen von Fritz.
Mit Max Käter. In der estnischen Hauptstadt Tallinn sind die Staats-
und Regierungschefs der Europäischen Union zu einem Sondergipfel zusammengekommen.
Bei einem gemeinsamen Abendessen sprechen sie über ihre jeweilige Vision von einem zukünftigen Europa. Ab morgen wollen sie dann in lockerer Atmosphäre über die weitere Digitalisierung Europas beraten. Dabei geht es unter anderem um den Ausbau des schnellen Internets, den Datenaustausch und die Cybersicherheit. Nach dem Fund mehrerer vergifteter Lebensmittel am Bodensee haben die Ermittler einige hundert Hinweise auf den Erpresser erhalten.
Vorher hatten sie Aufnahmen von Videokameras veröffentlicht, die den Verdächtigen zeigen. Bei dem Mann auf dem Bild soll es sich um den Unbekannten handeln, der von Supermärkten und Drogerien eine zweistellige Millionensumme erpressen will. Fünf vergiftete Gläschen Babynahrung wurden schon in Friedrichshafen am Bodensee gefunden.
Die Behörden raten deshalb in ganz Deutschland, beim Einkaufen darauf zu achten, dass Verpackungen nicht beschädigt sind. Russland und die Türkei wollen sich für die Schaffung einer Deeskalationszone in der syrischen Provinz Idlib einsetzen. Das sagte der türkische Präsident Erdogan nach einem Treffen mit Russlands Staatschef Putin.
Putin betonte, nach mehr als sechs Jahren Bürgerkrieg wollen Russland und die Türkei ihre Koordinierung vertiefen, um ein Ende der Kämpfe zu erreichen.
Während Russland seit September 2015 für den syrischen Machthaber Al-Assad Luftangriffe fliegt, unterstützt die Türkei die Rebellen.
Hertha BSC hat sein erstes Auswärtsspiel der Fußball Europa League Saison verpasst.
Beim schwedischen Östersunds FK gab es ein 0 zu 1.
In der 22. Minute verwandelte Östersund einen umstrittenen Handelfmeter.
Hertha muss jetzt mit nur einem Punkt aus zwei Spielen um den Einzug in die K.o.
Runde bangen. Außerdem hat in der Handball-Bundesliga haben die Berliner Füchse auswärts gegen den VfL Gummersbach gewonnen, und zwar mit 31 zu 29. Wetter Die aktuellen Temperaturen liegen in Berlin-Pankow bei 15, in Schöneberg bei 16 Grad, in Prenzlau sind 14 Grad, in Cottbus und Pritzwalk 15 und in Ciesa noch 16 Grad.
In der Nacht gehen die Temperaturen runter auf 12 bis 8 Grad und es kann von Westen her etwas regnen. Morgen wird's dann nach letzten Schauern wieder schöner und vor allem nachmittags gibt's viel Sonne und es bleibt dann meistens trocken mit 19 bis 24 Grad.
Da ist immer noch die B167 Selo Neu-Hardenberg dabei, am Bahnhof Selo Guzo schließen die Schranken nämlich nicht, fahrt besonders vorsichtig am Bahnübergang, denn die Züge fahren da auf Sicht.
Dann noch die A113, der Zubringer Schönefeld statt einwärts, ist gesperrt zwischen Schönefeld Nord-
und Atlashof, und zwar bis 5 Uhr früh wegen Wartungsarbeiten.
In Mitte ist unter den Linden in Höhe Glinkerstraße ein Ampelausfall, auch da bitte besonders vorsichtig, eine Kreuzung.
Und im Tiergarten ist die Straße des 17.
Juni gesperrt zwischen Brandenburger Tor und Großem Stern und auch die Ebertstraße ist zwischen der Rotin- und Wehrenstraße zu.
Außerdem noch ein Hinweis zur S-Bahn.
Die Ringbahnlinien S41 und S42 sind ab morgen früh bis Ende Oktober unterbrochen zwischen Gesundbrunn und Beusselstraße.
Am besten weich die auf andere S-
und U-Bahnlinien aus. Außerdem fahren auch Busse, die zusätzlich an den Bahnhöfen Humboldthain und Turmstraße halten.
Wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW. Und hier im Chaos Radio bei Fritz gibt es jetzt die Nerd-News, geschrieben von Moe vom Chaos Computer Club, präsentiert von Max Keeter.
Bürgerrechtsorganisation verabschiedet sich aus dem W3C. Die Electronic Frontier Foundation zieht sich aus dem World Wide Web Standardisierungskonsortium zurück. Sie begründet das mit der Verabschiedung der Encrypted Media Extensions, einem umstrittenen Kopierschutz im Browser. Streitpunkt ist vor allem der Teil, der Videos vor Raubkopien sichern soll. Dieser sei von der W3C-Führung und interessierten Unternehmen durchgesetzt worden, gegen die Interessen der Nutzer. Er liegt nicht im Quellcode vor und Sicherheitsforscher dürfen ihn nach dem DCMA-Gesetz zumindest in den USA nicht auf Schwachstellen prüfen. Browser wie Firefox und Chromium gelten vor allem wegen ihres offenen und nachvollziehbaren Open Source Entwicklungsmodells als sicher.
Das sei mit EME nicht mehr möglich.
Die Sicherheit von Internetnutzern werde so akut gefährdet.
Bitte nicht.
Ich muss erst lesen. CITES will nichts auf dem Schwarzmarkt kaufen.
Im Rahmen der Konferenz Public IT Security hatte Winfried Kahl, der Präsident der Zentralen Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich, seinen ersten öffentlichen Auftritt. Er werte sich dabei gegen die Bezeichnung seiner Mitarbeiter als Bundeshacker. Er sagte in seiner Rede, es sei nicht Aufgabe von CITES, Kommunikation unsicher zu machen.
Gegenüber Heise Online konkretisierte er, dass die Aufgabe gesetzlich festgelegt und gesetzesorientiert sei. Das bedeute auch, dass es keinen Ankauf von Zero Days auf Grau-
oder Schwarzmärkten gebe.
Es gebe auch keine Zusammenarbeit mit unseriösen Firmen, so Karl.
Gericht bestätigt Passwort-Herausgabezwang.
Ein Gericht in London hat den britischen Menschenrechtsaktivisten Muhammad Rabani verurteilt.
Der hatte sich bei der Einreise geweigert, Sicherheitsbeamten die Passwörter zu seinen IT-Geräten preiszugeben. Wie der Guardian berichtet, erhielt Rabani dafür eine Bewehrungsstrafe von 12 Monaten und eine Geldstrafe.
Das Gericht hat damit bestätigt, dass die britische Polizei die Passwörter von Einreisenden verlangen kann und wer sich weigert, begeht damit eine Straftat.
Ich streich London von meiner Reisezielliste und danke Max Keeter für die Präsentation der NerdNews.
Sehr gern.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal fritz.de slash Tipps.
Letzte halbe Stunde im Chaosradio in Blue Moon hier auf Fritz und wir sprechen nochmal mit Danimo, Elisa Katascha und Martin über Software, die die Auszählung der Stimmen ermöglichen, wie wir sie besser machen können. Wir waren jetzt gerade stehen geblieben vor den Nachrichten an dem Punkt, dass es in Ungarn zum Beispiel passiert ist, dass jemand, der eine Sicherheitslücke herausgefunden hat, sich damit strafbar gemacht hat. Wir haben es auch gerade in den NerdNews gehört, dass es in den USA Fälle geben kann, wo man softwarelich auf Sicherheitslücken untersuchen darf. Und jetzt wollte Martin gerade erzählen, er hat ja diese PC-Wahl-Software untersucht. Da gab es anscheinend auch so eine kleine Gefahrenstelle, Martin. Welche war das?
Richtig. Wir hatten festgehalten, dass quelloffene Software nicht nur demokratischer und auch günstiger sein kann, sondern auch sicherer ist. Und das hat sich allerdings auf Landesebene oder auf kommunaler Ebene noch überhaupt nicht durchgesetzt, diese Meinung. Ein statistisches Landesamt hat tatsächlich laut darüber nachgedacht, im Gespräch mit der Zeit uns wegen Eindringens in IT-Systemen anzuzeigen, weil wir eben diese Lücken öffentlich gemacht haben. Und wir mussten sie halt öffentlich machen, weil es keine andere Möglichkeit gab, für uns ernst genommen zu werden mit diesen Problemen in dieser Software, da prioritäre Software automatisch quasi resistent ist oder nicht offen für Vorschläge, um von außen die Sicherheit zu erhöhen oder Meldungen, dass Sicherheitsprobleme in solcher Software existieren, dass die nicht aufgegriffen werden von den Herstellern.
Ich habe gar nicht so viel Hand, wie ich mir gerade vor das Gesicht schlagen will. Also nicht nur so, dass die Software total veraltet ist und nicht im offenen Quercode folgt, sondern auch noch, dass man die Leute verfolgt, die sagen, hey, da ist was nicht in Ordnung. Wir wollen jetzt noch zu einem Konzept kommen, dass das alles besser machen kann. Und das ist ja sozusagen unter anderem zumindest ein Ziel des Prototype Funds. Elisa, erklär nochmal genauer, was dahinter steckt.
Genau, hinter dem Prototype Fund steht die Idee, dass wir festgestellt haben, dass es ganz viele Leute gibt, die schon offene Software entwickeln für Organisationen, für gemeinnützige Vereine und da richtig, richtig gute Arbeit leisten.
Und dass es für die keine Möglichkeit gab, an öffentliche Gelder zu kommen. Es wird so ziemlich alles mit öffentlichen Geldern gefördert von großen Automobilherstellern bis hin zu Universitäten.
Aber einzelne Leute haben so gut wie keine Möglichkeit, in Deutschland an Gelder zu kommen.
Ich will noch kurz eine Frage stellen. Also es gibt ja für Software sozusagen zwei Finanzierungsmittel. Das eine ist ja, ich lasse mich fördern sozusagen, also theoretisch zumindest. Das andere ist ja, ich baue die Software und verkaufe sie dann. Und das geht dann aber nicht so gut, wenn die Open Source ist? Das glaubt man gerne.
Das ist aber was, was glaube ich von den Leuten, die proprietäre Software, also Software, die nicht quelloffen ist und die da Geschäftsmodelle anschließend ja verbreitet wird. Tatsächlich fördern wir schon Projekte, die eigentlich genau das machen, dass sie offene Software entwickeln. Und die Services, hat Danimo vorhin auch gesagt, die dann anstehen, nämlich anpassen, das Ganze warten, dass sie das einfach als Geschäftsmodell haben, der Quellcode selber ist aber offen.
Also das Ziel der Förderung ist nicht sozusagen, dass jetzt irgendwie die idealistische Hippie-Software gefördert wurde, sondern einfach nur Voraussetzung ist, der Code muss Open Source sein. Und was dann damit passiert, ist egal?
Wir finden idealistische Hippies auch total toll.
Also ja, aber es ist sozusagen keine Grundvoraussetzung, die, okay, man kann auch sagen, ich habe hier dieses total geile Geschäftsmodell, mit dem ich mega reich werde, aber ich brauche eure Förderung am Anfang.
Das ist auch total legitim.
Okay, verstehe. Und jetzt kann ich mir auch vorstellen, wie viel hast du gesagt, 745?
Ne, pro Projekt gibt es knapp 50.000, genau 47.500 seit dieser Runde.
Und wie viele Projekte könnt ihr fördern?
Pro Runde fördern wir so um den Dreh 25.
Das ist ja schon ein bisschen Geld, aber auch nicht unendlich viel. Und jetzt würde ich mir vorstellen, wenn ich jetzt ankomme und sage, hey, ich habe voll die geile Software Idee und ich mache auch ein Open Source Versprechen, gib mir mal bitte knapp 50.000 Euro, dass ihr dann möglicherweise sagt, naja, wir hätten da schon noch so eine Anforderung. Wie sieht das aus? Also wie, also oder kann da wirklich jeder kommen und kriegt dann auch die Kohle? Und wer zuerst kommt, ist dann halt gefördert.
Na, wer zuerst kommt, mal zuerst ist es nicht, sondern wir haben immer Einreichungsphasen. Eine läuft gerade noch und zwar noch bis Samstag.
Also wäre gerade noch eine neue Wahl.
Stimmen, Sale und Addierungssoftware. Die gab es noch nicht?
Nee, ich habe noch nicht reingeguckt. Genau, also die Chance besteht noch. Und dann gibt es einfach eine Jury, die auch einsehbar ist auf unserer Webseite, die darüber entscheidet, die sich die Einreichungen durchguckt und die besten. Und auch ein breiteres Themenspektrum, der versucht, rauszuziehen.
Genau. Und da wird aber nur die Idee bewertet oder auch sagen, wie fit sind die Leute schon im Programmieren und wie erfolgreich sind die möglicherweise. Also nicht kommerziell, sondern in der Hinsicht irgendwie, dass sie die Software tatsächlich auch fertig stellen. Ja, es gibt verschiedene Kriterien, die da bewertet werden.
Natürlich fragen wir schon ab, was ist denn das? Keine Ahnung, euer GitHub Repo, gib das mal an. Wo habt ihr denn bisher so beigetragen?
Euer was?
Das GitHub Repository, also euer Open Source Code, den ihr schon bereitgestellt habt.
Also man muss quasi vorzeigen, was man schon mal gemacht hat.
Das ist ein Faktor von mehreren. Es ist kein Ausschlusskriterium, aber auf alle Fälle trägt das zu einer guten Bewertung bei. Es zählt natürlich auch die Idee, wenn die schon fünfmal da war und jemand das nur noch mal in Python umsetzen will, also in einer Programmiersprache, braucht es das vielleicht nicht unbedingt. Wir fragen auch nach gesellschaftlichem Mehrwert, also wie vielen Leuten kommt das Ganze denn am Ende zu Gute? Oder wenn die Gruppe von Menschen, die das braucht, richtig klein ist, brauchen die das vielleicht extrem dringend? Und es gibt so eine Art von Multiplikationseffekt dadurch. Es sind verschiedene Faktoren. Und ich glaube in einem dieser Faktoren findet man sich immer wieder.
Und das ist jetzt, also du hast gerade gesagt, in dieser Runde, wie lange gibt es das schon?
Das ist jetzt die dritte Bewerbungsrunde, die gerade offen ist und es wird insgesamt acht Bewerbungsrunden geben.
Gibt es schon eine, die abgeschlossen wurde?
Ja, eine wurde jetzt gerade Ende September abgeschlossen.
Aber ich meine abgeschlossen im Sinne von, da sind jetzt fertige Projekte?
Genau, das ist die erste Runde.
Die sind schon fertig.
Die sind schon fertig, genau. Die sind auch einsehbar auf unserer Webseite, da sind die verlinkt.
Was sind das für Projekte, wo man jetzt die Software quasi nachbauen kann?
Das ist extrem unterschiedlich. Also wir haben vier Bereiche, in denen wir fördern. Das sind Civic Tech, also im weitesten Sinne digitale Tools, die Organisationen, Vereinen oder Bürgerinnen und Bürgern zugutekommen. Es geht in den Bereich Datensicherheit, also ganz klassische Verschlüsselungsthemen. Es geht um Data Literacy, also gerade in dem ganzen Bereich. Wir haben zwar ganz viele Daten, die online zugänglich sind, aber wie verständlich sind die eigentlich? Was brauchen Menschen, um die gut nutzbar zu machen? Und so ganz knallharte Infrastrukturprojekte.
Aber kannst du ein konkretes Projekt nennen?
Auf jeden Fall. Wir hatten zum Beispiel ein Projekt, das heißt SignDict. Das ist ein online Wörterbuch für Gebärdensprache. Und das Tolle dabei ist, dass das ge-crowdsourced wird. Auf signdict.org kann jeder nicht nur Gebärdensprachen angucken und lernen, sondern eben auch, wenn man der Sprache mächtig ist, die da hochladen.
Und jetzt habt ihr gesagt, eine Voraussetzung ist, da soll der Code dann irgendwie auch öffentlich sein, dass man ihn einsehen kann. Legt ihr das doch fest, das muss auch für immer so bleiben? Man kann ja auch sagen, sonst komme ich hin und sage so, hey Leute, ich habe diese geile Softwareidee, ich mache den Programmcode offen und dann sagt ihr, hier 50.000 Euro, nicht so geil, hier ist meine Softwareversion. Ach so, ja Version 2.0 wird dann leider nicht mehr offen sein.
Also ich glaube, wer sich einmal dem Open-Source-Gedanken verschrieben hat, der geht davon nicht mehr so schnell weg, weil er einfach zu viele Vorteile hat.
Aber dann sagen, darauf baut ihr, es gibt da kein Regelwerk, das das irgendwie vorschreibt, dass man lebenslang nur noch in Open-Source veröffentlichen darf.
Auf alle Fälle sind ja auch alle Github oder alle Codes, die einmal veröffentlicht sind, können ja auch von anderen weiter verwendet werden, kopiert werden. Das heißt, es gibt einfach keine Möglichkeit, das wieder zurückzuziehen.
Es gibt überhaupt keine Handhabe.
Wie findet ihr anderen eigentlich dieses Projekt? Also weil das Ding ist ja auch, man denkt so, hey 50.000 Euro, da kann man schon was mitmachen. Wie weit reicht denn 50.000 Euro in der Softwareentwicklung? Oder anders gefragt, Martin, du hast dich doch ganz ausführlich jetzt mit dem Thema beschäftigt. Willst du nicht mal eine Stimmen aus Zählsoftware bauen? Und wenn ja, wie teuer wäre das?
Also dieser Gedanke, den haben wir tatsächlich angesprochen im Kreis von denen, die sich jetzt mit PC-Wahl beschäftigt hatten. Die Meinung dazu war dann eher, da muss es tatsächlich einen Impuls von oben geben. Also es muss nicht nur das Funding dazu bereitstehen, da so eine Wahlsoftware eine sehr komplexe Software ist, man sich beim Wahlrecht sehr gut auskennen muss. Man muss mit den Gemeinden zusammenarbeiten. Das kann nur auf kommunaler Ebene in Zusammenarbeit erstellt werden, so eine Software. Da muss der Impuls auch von den Gemeinden ausgehen oder beziehungsweise von oben, von den Anwendern. Die müssen auch quasi die Erkenntnis haben, dass diese Software auch eingesetzt werden muss offen. Denn es nützt ja auch nichts, jetzt so einen Prototyp zu erstellen, der danach nicht genutzt wird.
Naja, aber es ist ein bisschen, also beißt sich da die Katze nicht in den Schwanz, sondern weil, also dann sagt ihr so, naja, also wenn ihr wollt, wir würden ja machen. Und dann sagen die anderen, naja, wenn ihr was gemacht hättet, würden wir es auch einsetzen und dann kommen wir nie zu irgendwas.
Ich denke der Prototyp, also jetzt, wenn sich jemand findet, der sich damit auskennt, Problem ist aber nur, dass es eine Fachanwendung, Fachsport, die wirklich sehr speziell ist. Man muss sich, müsste jemand finden, der sich im Wahlrecht auskennt. Es müsste sich jemand finden, der diese Prozesse versteht, die zwischen Landes- und Kreiswahlleitern und Bundeswahlleitern ablaufen alle vier Jahre bzw. bei kommunalen Landeswahlen öfter. Der müsste quasi mit beratend dabei sein und es müsste ein Programmierer geben, der sagt, packen wir es einfach mal an, machen wir einen Prototyp. Und dann ist vielleicht die Hemmschwelle niedriger zu sagen. Jetzt von kommunaler Seite aus ist das tatsächlich möglich. Wir machen uns mal Gedanken darüber, ob wir das auch mal weiter ausbauen und einsetzen. Ja, so kann man das sehen. Dieses Hände-Eye-Problem kann man nur dadurch lösen, dass man einfach mal macht. Ja, so kann man das sehen.
Aber ich frage nochmal, was glaubst du, wie teuer sowas wäre?
Ja, also ich kann dir nur sagen, was bisher damit verdient wurde auf privater Seite. Also dieses PC-Wahlprogramm hat eine halbe Million im Jahr eingebracht, für eine Person, die das entwickelt hat. Also in den Kategorien kann man jetzt nicht denken. Wenn man ein Produktiv entwickelt, 50.000 für ein halbes Jahr, das ist schon in Ordnung für eine Person, zwei Personen, die sich daran setzen. Also quasi hauptamtlich oder zumindest nebenbei. Also ja, nur jeden, der da vielleicht Ambitionen hat, dazu motivieren.
Aber du bist es nicht, höre ich da auch aus, ja?
Ja, es braucht halt leider diese sehr viel Kenntnisse von Wahlrecht, um das ja auch richtig anzugehen vom Anfang an. Und es braucht natürlich auch Zeit.
Aber das interessante, was man auch mitnehmen kann, ist sozusagen, es ist immer einfacher, was kaputt zu machen, als es sozusagen neu zu bauen. Das ist auch ganz spannend. Dannimo, was ist deine 50.000-Euro-Idee? Ja, tatsächlich, würde ich noch einen anderen Aspekt reinbringen. Die sind 50.000 Euro. Also bauen, finde ich, da teile ich tatsächlich die Meinung. Da ist nämlich das Problem ja noch, jedes Bundesland ist bei uns anders, hat also auch ein komplett anderes Wahlrecht. Das heißt, du darfst dann irgendwie 16 verschiedene Implementierungen machen, wenn du Pech hast. Na gut, aber dann macht man es halt für Berlin. Genau, also man müsste dann tatsächlich erst mal eine Basis finden. Was ich jetzt sagen würde, ist, man kann das schon irgendwie versuchen. Zum einen, was Katascha sagte, die Awareness bei der Politik muss da sein, es müssen Gespräche geführt werden. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich auch so den Eindruck, dass es genug Leute geben würde. Es gibt ja dadurch, dass es 16 verschiedene Bundesländer gibt, es gibt auch verschiedene Bundeswahlleiter. Und da wird sich bestimmt jemand finden, der sagt, jetzt habe ich die Schnurze voll, ich leiere das mal an von mir aus. Die Software, was hat Martin gesagt, gefühlt irgendwie vor 30 Jahren geschrieben worden. Okay, umso besser, also sagen, ich... Ich weiß nicht, na gut. Ich bin ein bisschen unzufrieden. Ich hätte schon gewünscht, dass er so geil am Ende dieser Sendung geschrieben hat. Nein, wird noch ein bisschen länger dauern.
Wir kommen glaube ich nicht drum rum, dass der Staat kapieren muss, in welche Richtung sich das hinentwickeln muss. Weil natürlich ist die Wahlauswertungssoftware eine Baustelle, aber wir haben ja ganz viele Baustellen. Und da braucht es eben den grundsätzlichen Schalter, der umgedreht werden muss, dass man sagt, wir sehen so viele Vorteile, auch den Vorteil, dass beispielsweise, wenn staatlich finanzierte Software freie Software wäre, dann wird ja jedem Bürger auch freistehen, so hey, mir fehlt dieses Add-on-Modul beispielsweise für Gebärdensprache in diesem spezifischen Fall. Das ist eigentlich eine staatliche Aufgabe, aber in meinem Bundesland kriegen die halt nichts gebacken. Okay, dann machen wir das halt eben selber. Und da kann man eben auch vielleicht auch eine Initialzündung machen, um dann andere Bundesländer dazu zu bewegen, das dann doch selber hinzukriegen. Und mehr Synergien auch zwischen privaten Stellen oder NGOs oder Bürgerinitiativen und dem Staat zu schaffen, um im Endeffekt eine geilere Infrastruktur für uns alle zu erschaffen, die auch noch sicher ist.
Ich weiß nicht, wie zufrieden ich mich damit geben kann, dass wir jetzt auf einen Start warten müssen, aber Elinor wollte noch was sagen. Genau, also ich möchte in die gleiche Kerbe schlagen, und zwar der Prototype fand möchte Leute.
Und da wir unterstützen ihre coole Idee, für die sie sonst einfach noch nicht marktreif genug sind oder noch nichts vorzeigen können, die mal umzusetzen, mal anzugehen, sich Zeit zu nehmen. Es kann auch nicht unsere, ich mein, wir sind doch ein relativ kleines Projekt. Es kann auch nicht unsere Aufgabe sein, öffentliche Infrastruktur komplett neu zu erfinden. Das soll trotzdem niemanden abhalten, der sich gerade mit dem Gedanken trägt, das doch bei uns einzureichen, das einfach mal zu versuchen. Wir würden uns freuen, aber ausschließlich darauf würden wir uns auch nicht beschränken wollen.
Ich glaube, das ist auch ein Projekt, wenn man das denn wirklich aus privater Motivation machen wollte. Ich glaube, das wäre tatsächlich etwas, was man am besten irgendwie mit einem Verwaltungsrechtler zusammen macht. Also das ist tatsächlich, glaube ich, wie so vieles. Ich setze mich jetzt als findiger Hacker hin und mach mal. Kann man zwar tun, aber ich glaube, dann wird es recht schnell recht blöd. Man kriegt kein Feedback. Das wäre tatsächlich etwas, wo man sich mit jemandem, der was vom Fach etwas mehr versteht als derjenige, der sich da kundig einliest, zusammen machen könnte.
Was ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen kann, ist, dass vielleicht jemand jetzt diese Idee aufgreift und sagt, gut, wir machen jetzt erstmal keine komplette Wahlsoftware, sondern ich geh mal bei der Gemeinde vorbei, beim Wahlamt, hör mal, was die so einsetzen für die Stimmzettel-Erfassungssoftware. Das steht jetzt nämlich an bei den kommenden Kommunal- und Landtagswahlen. Werden tatsächlich auch die Stimmzettel elektronisch erfasst. Und da besteht in der Tat eine echte Manipulationsgefahr auch für die echten Wahlergebnisse, die amtlichen. Und da eine Software zum Beispiel zu schreiben, die quelloffen ist und dann die Stimmzettel noch im Wahllokal erfasst oder im Rathaus, wo die erst ausgezählt werden, das ist tatsächlich ein überschaubares Projekt und da könnte man mal anfangen.
Warte mal, hast du gerade gesagt, dass die Stimmzettel in Zukunft nicht mehr von der Hand ausgezählt werden, sondern durch bildgebende Verfahren im weitesten Sinne?
Die werden tatsächlich über jeder Stimmzettel einzeln bei Kommunalwahlen in verschiedenen Bundesländern in den Computer eingetippt und nur der Computer druckt dann sozusagen diese Schrift aus. Bei Bundestagswahl nicht, aber bei Landtagswahl schon.
Ich würde tatsächlich, was ich gerne sehen würde, jetzt wo ich diese Erfahrung als Wahleräffer mal gemacht habe, wozu ich übrigens nur aufrufen kann, macht es mal, damit ihr das selber nachvollziehen könnt. Wenn ihr schon keine Stimmausstellungssoftware habt. Macht doch mal irgendwas verdammt nochmal. Nein, aber die, wo ich wirklich nur zu ermuntern würde, ist diese Wahlniederschrift, finde ich eine gute Idee, diese Zusammenrechnerei zu automatisieren. Ich möchte hinterher einen gedruckten Zettel da haben, aber was mir wichtig wäre, ist, es passieren so, das ist ein einziger Schmierzettel, wenn es blöd läuft, weil man dann immer noch Ergebnisse korrigiert. Eigentlich hat man dafür Schmierpapier, aber dann denkt man sich, man hat das Ergebnis, dann zählt man nochmal nach und merkt, hm, da passt trotzdem was nicht. Je nachdem, wie erfahren das Team ist. Und da wärs eigentlich schöner, wenn man eine Software hätte, die an der Stelle beim Zusammenrechnen hält. Also im Prinzip so ein fancy Excel, sag ich mal. So, das ist auch ein in Anführungszeichen überschaubares Projekt, zumindest wenn man es erstmal auf eine Gemeinde oder so oder auf ein Land beschränkt. Und das kann man ja auch machen, ohne dass man jetzt einen Stimmzettelerfassungs- Scanner macht, sondern im Gegenteil. Ich möchte eigentlich etwas, wo Leute manuell zählen und gegenchecken können und wo ich hinterher auf Papier noch ein nachprüfbares Ergebnis habe, dann kann ich ja hinterher immer noch gucken, ob das, was da zusammenzermutiert hat, wirklich stimmt im Notfall. Also das, was heute schon archiviert wird, das würde dann weiterhin so archiviert auf totem Holz. Alles klar, wie gut siehst du die Chance, mein Prostetab fand? Man kommt jetzt an und sagt so, hier Stimmung auszähl, ist das für das Wahllokal?
Ich kann also leider vorher keine Aufmerksamkeit.
Kannst du es persönlich für eine gute Idee halten?
Ja, was ich auch noch mal auf jeden Fall unterstreichen würde, ist, wir müssen aufpassen, dass dieser Heck jetzt nicht als Window of Opportunity gesehen wird für ein paar Anbieter von kompletter Wahlsoftware, ihre Produkte, die angeblich super sicher sind, zu verkaufen. Weil ich bin tatsächlich jemand, der sagt, ich möchte, dass weiterhin Menschen wie du im Wahllokal per Hand das nachzählen. Und wenn wir den Prozess komplett automatisieren, dann haben wir eine ganz andere Manipulationsmöglichkeit, eine ganz andere Ebene. Und da würde ich tatsächlich sagen, das kann doch so sehr freie Software sein. Ne, das möchte ich nicht.
Also okay, das halte ich jetzt tatsächlich aber auch so zu sagen. Also ich bin nicht mal auf die Idee gekommen, dass man den Gedanken haben könnte, hey, die Software zur Ausländerung der Stimmen, die ist eigentlich gar nicht so sicher. Lass uns doch einfach das ganze Ding digital machen.
Du wirst lachen, es gab entsprechende Zeitungsartikel. Ich meine, das war tagespielig. Ich müsste noch mal nachgucken. Da hat jemand tatsächlich gesagt, wir brauchen eine richtig moderne IT-Strategie jetzt. Das heißt Wahlcomputer. Und es gibt ja Wahlcomputer, wo erfolgreich Pac-Man und Schach installiert wurde.
Also da kann ich empfehlen, wie war die Chaos-Radio Nummer 137 oder sowas? 117. Hört Chaos-Radio 117, dann wisst ihr, warum das auf jeden Fall eine ganz, ganz, ganz schlechte Idee ist. Wir verabschieden uns an dieser Stelle und rufen euch auf programmiert Wahl-Lokal-Stimmen-Austell-Software oder geht auf jeden Fall als Wahlhelferin. Ich bedanke mich bei Martin, Katascha, Elisa und Danimo. Und informiert euch immer gut, wie eure Stimmen denn letztlich verwendet und ausgezählt werden. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich sage an dieser Stelle Tschüss, verweise auf die Gitarrenmusik, die es hier nach Mitternacht gibt, von Tobi Scharper im Stahlwerk und habe ansonsten noch eine Nachricht für euch. Lasst sie nicht überwachen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Pack-ups.